Film Courage: Geoff you always intended to be a
film director but your life took a different turn?
Geoff Ryan, Filmmaker/Photographer: I mean
earliest memories I was coloring on the walls
with crayons and getting in trouble and writing
little stories and stuff like that and then
I was like 12 I took a summer one week animation
program and just fell in love with the moving
images seeing my drawings come to life and became
obsessive about that and met a lifelong friend
there, cinematographer Jarin Blaschke and he and
I in high school decided hey let's try live action
and then realizing people move on their own you
have to draw them a thousand times to get them to
walk across a room uh just fell in love with that
and so really since you know at least my teens the
moving image and filmmaking and storytelling
through that medium really helped um was in
some little festivals. I was at the Portland
young people's film festival had a couple of
early awards there and stuff like that so and just
getting the audience feedback was so addictive too
um and so yeah it was kind of a you know at least
a childhood goal for sure and art school was
kind of a compromise i did i did a year of it uh
before dropping out but i always loved you know i
had a background in drawing painting all that sort
of stuff and just love all mediums really and uh
but um but yeah i kind of just felt like
filmmaking and art in general was in brain
surgery so after a year of film school moved
to new york and started paying and just kind of
finding my way from there and when did you come
to los angeles uh five years ago now um it was
after frey came out uh i had a handful of people
telling me i'd be an idiot not to live in la
if i wanted to keep pursuing that course
and taking advantage of those opportunities
and i would try to fly back and forth a handful
of times and you know you'd set up meetings and
stuff like that and then you arrive in l.a you've
got a few days and they're like oh can we push the
meeting back to next week it's like uh no and
so um after a while i was just like yeah i kind
of need to be out here and also there had been an
exodus from new york of a lot of my colleagues and
friends have been coming out here so when i came
to l.a i actually had a better creative circle of
people to uh to join so just seemed like a natural
progression to come out here better way of life
more space i mean this room alone is bigger than
any of my apartments in new york uh so it's just
it's a better it's a better for me it's been a
better creative and professional choice for sure
your directing reel is gorgeous and you have
so many artistic shots even of the client work
that you've done you could really see the the
detail and the angle and how you you you know
the composition was that your plan all along to
sort of pay the bills doing client work and make
indie films on the side not a bad plan by the way
yeah um i've been really fortunate in that regard
uh way back you know i was trying to
make it work i was waiting tables and
busing tables and doing whatever odd jobs i could
back in new york and just really trying to find
ways to get my freelance career up and running
i mean i did everything from this dates myself a
bit i did a public access tv show for a while um
i was just constantly trying to find ways to do
things and then i fell into doing some
music videos early on which was great
um but uh even then wasn't a you know enough
to support myself and a few evictions and
apartment changes later i was like i got
to figure this out and fell into kind of
the world of doing fashion videos first was
internals and it started being in store videos
and then after a number of years of doing that i
was doing commercials for a couple notable fashion
brands and that was just a great experience
because you're working with some of the top
fashion photographers in the industry and kind
of learning a lot from them about lighting
composition just framing and what that does
to the perception of a person working with
great stylists and hair and makeup teams and
creative directors i had so much to add to
the aesthetic aspect of filmmaking um which just i
think heightened the storytelling sensibilities as
well and then also as a way to pay the bills it's
great um you know even uh even the small jobs are
uh there's always something that you're
learning from it it's uh you know getting
to see different locations and what one of
the locations that uh my new film uh blood
from stone's based around i discovered while on
his shoe we were doing a shoot in nevada and we
were staying in laughlin and i was just walking
on the riverwalk in laughlin i'm like this is
an amazing you know you got the casinos on one
side and this raging river on the other side and
it was just such a surreal place i'm like i gotta
shoot something here one day so oh sorry i'm sorry
was that part of uh where the main character
the protagonist where she was jogging yeah yeah
that was that exact river walk and about the same
stretch i was having that thought process while i
was walking it um yeah it was uh there was we were
staying in one of those casinos and i i actually
just went for a walk one night and walked all
the way along the river and across the other side
and uh yeah it was such a fascinating place uh and
even in the casinos and the casinos in laughlin
are a different breed than the ones i was familiar
with in vegas the big blitzy glamorous ones
they're a little more quaint a little more run
down clientele is a different type of clientele
and it was just it was there's so
many stories just happening there at
any given time that i just kind of had
a fascination and a bit of an obsession
and just always had that place in mind and
then this story just worked so well with
yeah i think reno is like that as well
parts of it i don't know if you've been
but there is a sort of a nice uh i don't know if
it's the right word but desperation that's added
into the storytelling yeah i think works so well
with that with that uh you know the gambling and
the money it does and that's i mean i'm a big fan
of uh location symbolism in my films i mean i've
got the two features to speak for that
fray was obviously you know shooting the
the epic forests of uh of the pacific northwest
and including the logging industry into it as
sort of a metaphor for what happens to our
men and women who we send off into combat
and with this one it was similar it's a movie
about vampires and what better place than casinos
for uh the symbolism of just these machines
that suck the the life savings out of people
and you know so it was it was kind of a
natural fit as well it's like where else would
you know those that have to only exist at
night be able to have a normal existence in
a casino town that never sleeps so um
so yeah it was a very uh to me it was
i like exploring that within the film the
making the locations and the environments
a part of the story the symbolism the and themes
throughout it because it just you know it gives
what i did fray actually it was i almost thought
i was just being pretentious by doing that
um i was like oh nobody's going to pay attention
to this i was really pleasantly surprised how
many people in audiences would talk about
that afterwards about about the symbolism
of the the force seeing the the logging and
the the wood splintered by the machines and
him cleaning up the debris of that juxtaposed with
him dealing with his own physical wounds from war
and then the peace you would find out in the
forest with these big tall standing trees and the
quiet there and just that back and forth it was
amazing to see how that spoke to audiences and how
how much they pulled from it and so i kind of was
inspired to just keep going with that in this film
and really weave so much of the environment
into the actual storytelling itself not just
cool places to shoot but what do they say
some of the places we shot at were very
very historic places uh pioneer saloon has been
there since i think 1912 or 1913 it's an old
frontier saloon that it still has a bullet hole
in the tin wall from a gun you know a gun fight
back in the old days and um we had atomic liquors
which is uh the oldest freestanding bar in las
vegas where people would go watch the atomic bomb
blasts back in the day while having some cocktails
and el cortez casino which is
the oldest independently owned
casino in vegas and still keeps
so much of its original character
and all those things to kind of play with the idea
of the symbolizing the old world and the old eras
contrasting with our new eras that's trying to
you know arise or from from these old eras and
so bringing a lot of symbolism in through
those location choices i think i think helps
uh really bring the the film together in a
much more uh realistic and fleshed out way
hoping to go back to your film that was about
military personnel returning to civilian life
and so that was based on a family member or lucy
based yeah yeah loosely based my cousin ben he was
a marine in iraq and did multiple tours and you
know he and i growing up uh you know we're close
cousins we lived in different states the time i
was in montana he was in oregon and washington
but we'd always meet up at grandparents place and
play military and i'd be the commander he'd be my
little soldier and then you know flash forward
15 years later and he's in the marines and i'm
an artist but uh you know he was in uh he was in
an ied attack over there uh his leg was hit with
shrapnel and then through an ambush a bullet also
hit him and obviously hospitalized for a long time
and when he came out i was visiting home and saw
him over the holidays and we were talking about it
and he just said something that was mind blowing
to me he said uh you know he was fortunate because
he had a family that he could go and stay with
but dealing with like a lot of the bureaucracy
around um the uh you know support for the
veterans uh he was saying that a lot of
the guys he knew in the hospital went straight
from the hospital to the streets if they didn't
have a place to go because their disability pay
would take so long to uh to be able to come in
and that just boggled my mind and so i spent
about two years on and off in my free time
just getting to know a lot of homeless vets a
lot of them in new york went down to dc and met
a couple and just wherever i would go i
try to find someone to speak to and just
hear their stories and some of them i spent a
couple days with walking in the distance kind
of observing seeing how people portrayed
them how they handled social situations
one of them was sleeping in a car out in the woods
another one i spent a night under a bridge with uh
just trying to as much as i could understand
that and then bring it to life in in a way that
i was hoping for other people like me who are
naive about the reality that our combat vets
face coming back home i was hoping it would be an
eye-opener to kind of walk in their shoes for an
hour and a half and get a sort of unflinching
look at the struggles emotional physical
uh systemic and social that they deal with and
i was pleasantly surprised when it all came out
that veterans themselves who i didn't think would
be as into it because they've already lived it um
but how it really became an important film for
a lot of of actual combat vets who felt like
watching that they did they're like well if some
filmmaker told the story must not just be me so
it helped some of them realize they're not alone
in that struggle that there's others out there
that are dealing with same issues you know they
have such a self-reliance that's bred into them
through through their military training through
you know their literally i mean their forces of
nature when they're in combat and they come
back and they're dealing with these issues
and it's almost an embarrassment to admit that
they're dealing with depression that they're
dealing with social isolation financial issues
all that sort of stuff and so to to showcase it
in that way where they can see that this is a
systemic issue it's not a personal flaw theirs
that it's something that's happening to a lot
of people it's great to see that response to
it as well um obviously it was something that was
personally really important to me uh it was also
in my own way i'm something that's politically
i trying to be too heavy-handed in my films
but i was very much an anti-war advocate back
in the early days and still am the early days
of those wars and it was to me it was a way
to make an anti-war film that would speak to
pro-war people and let them see you know it's not
um it's not about uh whether the war was right or
wrong it's about the aftermath of it and so
if you're going to start a war think about
the consequences of it what you're going to be
doing to those men and women we send over there
uh and so that it was great to see the
conversations i started i mean for such
a small film that really uh i was proud of the
impact it had right i did you watch a lot of
films like coming home and things like that from
the vietnam era this is almost embarrassing i
didn't even know about the film coming home until
uh one of the reviews of frey actually mentioned
like compared it to coming home i was like oh
um i'd actually hadn't seen rambo the first
one at the time i'd seen some of the later
ones i hadn't seen the first one at the time
i hadn't seen born on the fourth of july uh but
i had seen hurt locker i'd seen apocalypse now
platoon so i've seen a lot of actual war movies
and some of them that touch on those aspects of
the coming home experience but one of my
main things about it was some of the the
kind of newer braid of films that was coming
out around that time about the war and about
that experience i felt like there was still so
much melodrama that was brought into it um almost
like a hollywoodization of the story and because
it was such a low budget film it was just mine
i had the commercial career to survive on i wasn't
concerned if it ever made a dime i just wanted to
make one that showed it in its most authentic way
even brian the actor who played the main character
uh you know he spent some time with a home for uh
kind of like a halfway home for uh homeless vets
or dealing with like addiction issues and stuff
like that got to know a lot of them really well
and one of our main focuses on it was to you know
there was no score in the movie his acting was
very naturalistic there's only a few big flare-ups
a lot of the time it was more him trying to
suppress those those feelings and not show his
weaknesses or what he was struggling with um
and just like if at any moment this feels like
someone's watching a movie you and i have failed
you know we would talk about like as an actor and
as a director we failed if this feels like a movie
i would want it to feel like an experience and
one of the best compliments i've ever gotten and
brian as well i was after our premiere there was a
gentleman there who was a marine combat vet and he
he told brian he's like every moment of that film
i've lived and a lot of it i still live every day
and i believed you were a marine up until i saw
you do push-ups and i was like no he's an actor
so it was just it was great to see that kind of
response i mean it was it was a gamble um you
know it's not an exciting film it's a very uh as
a buddy put it he's like i'm not i didn't enjoy it
but i'm really glad i watched it um it's uh it's a
film that's a challenge for for the audience it's
supposed to be a little upsetting it's supposed
to be slow at times it's repetitive it shows
his day-to-day cycles of dealing with the
same issues over and over again and how
that unravels his um almost his willingness
to cope with it and uh um you know there's no
loose ends that are tied up at the end characters
drop off left and right because often times when a
ptsd attack happens a lot of the vets i know they
would just flee um you know they would disappear
that go inward and it would sever they would sever
ties with people and so address that in there so
characters don't have arcs in it because a
lot of times in life there isn't a full arc
um so it's not a it's not a typical story in
that way but i thought it was essential to do it
that way because it's the most effective way to
express the real struggle of somebody like that
and i think you said that you had maybe thought
of doing a documentary but you couldn't bring
yourself to film them so then you turned it into
a narrative yeah is that correct that is that's
exactly it i really you know a lot of those vets
that i was going around and meeting and getting to
you know to try and understand it i
was i would bring a camera with me
with the intent of at some point getting them on
camera talking about it and showing their life
but you know a lot of them were very guarded
about this again it's not something that you
know nobody's proud of being homeless nobody's
going to talk openly about it a lot of them
were embarrassed at where they were at didn't
like to admit the struggles they were having
and even just the fact they trusted me to open
up to and to let me do that i mean sometimes it
would take a few meetings for them and um to get
to really be comfortable with me and understand
that i had the best of intentions and was just
there to listen um not coming in with an agenda
and so by the time they would finally open up and
start talking about the last thing i wanted to do
is throw a camera in their face i was just like
that just felt to me vulgar to even think about
so i would just sit and listen and um you know
almost be just somebody for them to talk to
and it was amazing how how much they were
willing to share with me for that and so i
just realized like i can do i can do inspiring
documentaries for somebody who's talking about
overcoming adversity i can talk you know do
that kind of thing but getting into like that
i actually had the pleasure of meeting now
eugene jarecki one time and asked him how he
does it because some of the interviews he does
are i mean i i just seen the house i live in and
he's interviewing a guy who's been sentenced to
prison you know 20 year old guy and uh asked him
afterwards like how he how he can even do that and
he's like his camera was exact words or something
like i feel like a monster doing it but i just
keep on thinking about the end goal it's like
this is more important for other people to see
this than for me to feel good about recording it
um and i admire him as a documentarian to
be able to overcome that sense of guilt in
that moment but uh for me it was just easier
to take in all that and then craft it into
a narrative based on those real stories
and tell it that way and i also feel like
in the end it was the right choice beyond just my
own creative struggles with being a documentarian
it was the right choice because it
reached an audience that a documentary
would not have reached uh you know people that
were open to watching it in its film forum form
may not have been as open to it in a documentary
which oftentimes documentaries are kind of
perceived to already have a political or social
agenda this film wasn't necessarily perceived
that way and overtly it doesn't it just kind of
shows this is what it is make of it what you will
but yeah uh so that's a part of why the film had
that naturalistic tone and even the the short
film you'd mentioned was sort of an experiment to
see if i could pull it off because i hadn't done
i hadn't done a very naturalistic film before
my shorts and experiments before that were a
little bit more in the uh i would say in the uh
you know oliver stone over the top sort of mold
um so it was a new way for me to kind of go into
this more natural realistic approach and yeah i'm
glad i did it that way because it was uh it was
a huge learning curve for me as well as just an
incredible experience at what point did you
realize though this is not just going to be
a little indie film that'll live on youtube i
think you said just for a few friends to see
what point did it cross over to a new new audience
it really yeah it was uh when i started up on it i
definitely had the sense that nobody was gonna
watch it um like this is just i mean it's not a
it's not a fun movie to watch and uh um you
know even the festival circuit uh which was
a fascinating on its own uh you know we started
getting awards which i was shocked by um and uh
um but even then like with the distribution
process you know signed up with indie rights
and linda and michael at indian rights
are just godsends they're great people
uh but um it was literally the day of
our premiere our theatrical premiere
in la here and i was on the balcony with linda
and we just got in the la times review we had
a quarter page review with our picture you know
picture of the film and it was a phenomenal review
linda says to me she's like you starting to
think maybe you have a good film now i'm like
everybody else seems to think so so i guess
so um it really it was shocking to me because
i mean i guess any creative goes through this when
you look back at your film as or as you're working
on it you see nothing but flaws and failure
and things you wish you'd done differently
and it wasn't until the second night of the
screening where we had a guest who came his name
was sergeant justin bond he was a army vet from
uh who had been in the fight in fallujah and lost
his leg in it and he and i were having a great
chat before the film and sat next to each other
through the screening of the film it was
amazing to experience it that way because
sitting next to this guy who's truly lived the
story i made a film about and there were moments
where i got a little chuckle for him every now
and then he'd whisper some little snide remark in
my ear but also you could feel his emotions going
through and so i almost got to experience it fresh
through him being able to kind of see it how he
was seeing it for the first time and that was the
first time i ever got to actually experience my
my own film and enjoy it um it was very grateful
for that experience for uh for being able to see
it through his eyes in a way in terms of just
having his reactions right next to me while he was
seeing it and being like oh oh that did work okay
so yeah it wasn't really until the second day
of our theatrical premiere that i felt like okay
this film is actually decent
and it's going to go somewhere
and then it was a few few weeks later
back in new york a gentleman who was a
army psychologist in afghanistan was back
giving a talk to a handful of doctors in
new york about ptsd and he invited me to it and
literally told the doctors at this meeting when
he ended it he would reference the film a few
times and even a clip from it that he showed
but he said if you want to understand what
our vets go through when they come back home
watch this gentleman's film and pointed to
me and so afterwards you know talked with a
few of the doctors told them where they could
watch it stuff like that um so there's moments
like that where really was like okay this
this was actually it's a small indie film
but it was something special it really just the
people that it was intended to hit it really hit
i find that interesting though because you
you said before i think in another interview
that anything that could have been said
about your film or maybe other films
you've maybe said worse about your own work and
i'm wondering if that almost makes someone better
that um i hope all the self-abuse isn't
just just a waste of time um it uh
it is i mean i try to always look for the
positive in what i'm doing obviously it's
what keeps me going but yeah the self-criticism
i really i mean i've gotten some bad reviews in
the past and every single one of them like
oh yeah i can see that that makes sense
you know uh the only one that i didn't get
and this was it was an amazon comment was they
they said they hated this the music and fray
i'm like there's no score you're talking about
there had to be some troll yeah that was
the only one i've ever disagreed with
there was a comment on imdb about frey and i
thought it was interesting that you incorporated
this part that you mentioned earlier about the
self-reliance and i think the commenter or the the
reviewer put um that the main character and fray
justin rejects anything he interprets as charity
yeah did you pick up on that from meeting
these vets when you saw them definitely in
fact there's a line in the short film uh this
uh gentleman uh this older guy offers him he's
walked on the street it's rainy day offers
him a ride and after he drops him off um
at uh basically at the edge of the forest where
the uh the character is sleeping uh he offers
him uh he's like i got some groceries in the back
and i gave you something like a beer or something
and there's a moment where uh justin the veteran
hesitates and the guy says to him it's not charity
it's thanks and he takes it and that was kind of
the theme of that short film was the idea of like
you know these things that we need to do to
help our returning combat vets it's not about
charity it's a thanks it's for what
you know what they've sacrificed
um and that was to a lot of returning
vets again it's that self-reliance pride
they don't want charity they don't see themselves
as a charity case and so um and you know it's not
just with vets i mean you know i've i've seen
even in my own life as an artist i've had my
ups and downs sometimes where you know you don't
want to ask for help and but you need it and you
know what that does to your psyche when you feel
when you feel like a charity case and so i really
wanted to address that and kind of brought my
own personal experiences with being down and out
having to sleep on somebody's sofa or not knowing
how you're going to eat and having to ask a friend
for ten dollars or whatever it might be um try
to bring that into it and just show that it's
okay to be down and out sometimes like everybody
has the potential to fall through the cracks um
it doesn't make you a bad person it doesn't
mean that you failed uh it just means that as
as a society we should help lift each other up
and so i kind of wanted to express that in the
film the best i could within within that story
there was actually i mentioned earlier when uh
brian had spent some time with this home with uh
vets he mentioned that there was a construction
site across the street at one point somebody just
a big two by four or some something had fallen and
clapped against some other wood and he said it was
fascinating for him to observe the reaction of the
vets there versus his own like to him was like oh
what was that to them it was like on guard like
um just immediate response even vietnam vets guys
i've been back for 35 40 years terrible with math
however long it's been you know older gentleman
who had been back a long time would steal that
that loud sound out of nowhere just set him
on guard and uh so yeah yeah the fireworks
are not good for for that at all no and there
were a lot of them this year yeah how has your
directing style evolved from your first film to
now uh thankfully it's evolved from my first film
early on i really was much more focused on uh
story and theme oftentimes at the expense
of uh the really the film experience uh and
over time and just through just repetition
of trying you know uh shooting constantly
learning more about it um to me it's much more now
about the psychology and the visceral experience
you know still enjoy some good dialogue that sort
of thing but really it's to me it's not about
what's said as much as about what is experienced
by the audience and that was the biggest change
for me conceptually which has really changed
the way that i approach directing now one of the
biggest things for me has been getting to a point
where i trust my actors to know the character
as well if not better than i do so that way the
choices they make on screen are natural to them
that it's not me telling them to do this it's them
deciding that's what the character needed to do
this is what the character would have done in
that moment same thing with really almost any
department on a film i want whoever is there
i want them to feel empowered that they're
there because they know exactly what this film
needs for that moment there's been times where
that hasn't worked i've had to step in and take a
more dictator type approach um but most the time
i really like having that sort of environment on
set where everybody feels like they are an active
contributor to the creative output of the film to
what it's actually saying um but again especially
with actors i think it's just so key that they
feel comfortable and that they're not being
judged that they're not you know i don't ever want
them to feel like they made the wrong choice i'll
say something like instead of saying oh no don't
do it that way do it this way instead i'll say
that was great but how if we try it
this way um that was really good but
let's just try maybe a little bit more uh a
little bit more anger or a little bit more
sarcasm or something like that and try
to find those ways to where they always
they never feel like they did it wrong and vanya
the lead in blood from stone he started joking
with me about it whenever he said he did it great
like you mean i sucked like no he didn't suck
um so he caught on to some of my tricks uh
but it really is it's it's uh because it
is initially a wrong choice there is no wrong
choice uh it's all about you know knowing how
to get it to where i wanted to go and honestly
one of the greatest things for me as a director
is all the work i've done as an editor and as
a dep i really i didn't set out to do either of
those i just did them out of necessity because
i had no budgets uh and so you know you got i
just had to figure it out myself um but doing
that especially like you know doing interviews
for clients you know we do an hour-long interview
and i have to edit it into a one-minute video um
all that type of stuff over the years has helped
me when i'm directing when i'm watching a scene
i can see it and edit it in my mind and know we
got that line we got that line oh no we didn't
get that line okay that was a decent and then i
can kind of just keep that organized in my brain
so that i don't yell or i don't say that you
know to move on to the next scene or the next
part until i know we've gotten all it takes
we need for it to come together and editing
and that's been a huge huge help because early
on i was just never sure if we had it i'm like i
think we do and i get into editing i'm like oh no
no we didn't get it uh so that's been a huge help
too is just finding you know finding those great
moments and being able to file it away in my brain
like seeing the edit as it's happening and even to
a certain extent my screenwriting i mean i write
an edited film i mean this uh fray and this
one the the scene count is obscene because
it's a lot of back and forth between scenes
um so literally my script is almost verbatim
what you see on camera with the exception of some
improv by the actors but uh scene organization uh
just everything flows exactly as it is in the
final film there's only uh one one scene that
got cut and one that or two that got shortened
a little bit jeff can we talk about the budget
for frey i understand you financed it through
various jobs yeah yeah so um i was i was kind
of fortunate after i did the short film the little
experiment for fray um we literally wrapped that
on the day that the housing market and lehman uh
collapsed um which was a terrible time to just
spend your meager savings on a film and then
not have a job for six months um and so but i
was kind of fortunate in a way that after those
six months when companies started hiring again
they weren't they didn't have the budgets to go
with the big ad agencies and i had a couple of my
fashion clients that were like well this jeff guy
that's been doing our uh you know internals and
our in-store videos this stuff's basically as good
as the agencies we hire let's just have him do our
commercials and so i kind of got really lucky um
started landing a couple of you know i mean they
were hiring me much less than what they would hire
for a big production company or an agency but for
me it was a lot and so i was able to put away
some savings uh over the course about two years
and um was able to pull it off and then also
just lucky and i wrote it with brian in mind
he and i had done the short film and we'd known
each other a while knowing you know that i had
jaren as my cinematographer on it who uh you know
obviously is one of the best cinematographers of
this generation you know i've always felt that
way fortunately he's kind of gotten there now
having jody as the producer you know had a
great circle of friends that brought to life
and then shooting in oregon was a huge help too
um you know it was a lot of people there one they
believed in the story they really believed in
what we were trying to do with it so we got um
you know uh we got people all the all the cars for
the film were donated to us uh all the locations
with exception of two we got for free we got the
wood mill for free we just had to have insurance
you know just so much we were able to get and
people were so helpful with it the employment
agency seen actually when we were talking to the
woman who owned that actual employment agency
she said that if we needed extras she
would reach out to her network of uh
people who were looking for work so that's how
i really get so many extras for the film uh
it was just um yeah so in terms like
pulling it off for a smaller budget
it was um it just took a lot of favors uh but um
you know like i said because i that commercial
world you know was our budget on that was probably
the craft services budget for like an a24 film um
but it was still enough that we were able to
pull off something with all those all those other
people really putting their heart and soul into
it and one of my proudest things about that was
so many of the local people that worked on it it
did end up elevating their careers some of them
was their first film they'd ever worked on and you
know i wrote everybody a letter recommendation for
whatever they wanted to do because i'm like
if you worked on this film you had your hands
in every department so um i mean there were there
were entire days where was literally myself jaron
brian another whoever the other actor was and
matt who was a pa like that was the entirety of
our production it was just you know it was three
people and two actors or three actors at a time
for days on end so as a you know everybody
on it just put in so much and so they
a lot of their careers got elevated by it which
was so great to see because we've all worked on
no budget films that when we were done with
like well that was a waste of three days or
five days or whatever so knowing that the people
that came on board were able to go on and do more
afterwards and were elevated by this film was just
something i was really proud of as well because
it's a hard industry so being able to help
lift others up is is a good feeling so you
knew how much you had in this bank account or bank
accounts or whatever when when you started to dip
past a certain point and and maybe the clock
was ticking what was your mindset uh um i when
when the funds were running low it was uh it was
nerve-racking had to compartmentalize because the
the anxiety meltdown that was happening just put
that in this box over here and this box over here
is like well if you don't finish the film then you
just ruined your life for nothing so um it was and
we actually had we took a three-day hiatus because
i had a client that wanted me to do a commercial
a little web commercial it was like yeah we'll
put on hiatus i literally took the last of the
money i had and gave it to jaron who was stuck in
portland for three days um while i was away and
you know basically went back to new
york did a shoot and flew right back
i didn't get paid for it for another month but at
least had that coming in and then really grateful
marissa the lead actress in it her parents gave uh
i should remember this i think it was two thousand
dollars to us to help out um my own parents
threw in a thousand dollars um and helped cover
some of the hotel costs for us so you know it was
fortunate like family and friends really pitched
in my girlfriend at the time kim she set up a
paypal account where people could make donations
that helped bring a couple hundred more dollars in
um just really just crawled across the finish line
and uh and then when i when we wrapped
you know got back to new york and just
took like the next three months just doing
as much client work as i could because
um i wasn't going to have a home for much longer
if i didn't and i didn't want art to uh or life
to imitate art that much so so it sounds like
it was kind of rah-rah out of the gate and then
piecemeal at the end it was that's kind of how
you finished it yeah it was i mean definitely
we knew i mean the budget was so small and
i guess at this point i can say i mean we
literally went into this shoot with just over
twenty thousand dollars um obviously we spent
a lot more over the course of the film but
that was what we're starting with on it and
uh that's not a lot uh that doesn't stretch very
far when you're trying to when you've got to fly
some cast and crew out to new york and house them
and feed them or out from new york to oregon house
and feed them transportation logistical costs and
uh you know just some other checks would come in
from projects i'd done a few months before add
that to the budget um and again my girlfriend
at the time kim she was managing uh managing all
the finances she would watch my bank account and
tell me where i was at and she'd be like you guys
need to spend less money on coffee like i can't
that's that's not a compromise we can make
right especially not in oregon no i don't know the
coffee are they comparable to yeah seattle yeah
yeah um there was a place uh that we were just
hooked on and brian still talked about to this
day he's like i just i want to go back for their
coffee um yeah it was uh it was intense that's for
sure uh every dollar on that one mattered i mean
all the wardrobe that we bought came from goodwill
uh you know again and just every
favor we could get was uh was a
was just essential i mean if we hadn't gotten
all the favors we had gotten there's no way that
film would have happened so and sorry you shot
right before the actual quote-unquote meltdown
the the lima brothers that was the short film
uh poor the one that does an experiment for frey
so that was right before that meltdown
so i guess i was ahead of the curve in
terms of talking about uh you know just financial
precarity uh and obviously it inspired the script
in this one you know thus why marissa's character
is a teacher of uh morals and uh economics um
uh i forget the specific term which is terrible
but uh but yeah so you know wedge that in there
in terms of as a way to discuss some of those
higher ideas without being too heavy-handed i hope
um but yeah i was definitely heavily inspired
by that because you know it just it's so
easy to fall through the cracks as an artist
i've seen it you know as a freelancer and an
artist you know it's feast or famine sometimes
things are great and then you know buy a new
set of lenses and then you don't get a job for six
months you're like oh god that was a stupid choice
and so you know i know how easy it is and
granted for me a lot of those financial decisions
are not essentials a set of lenses isn't an
essential it's a good business investment i mean
i've used the same set of lenses now
for six seven years and they're gorgeous
staying with camera you know drop 20 30 grand
on a camera that's a lot of money that's
you know it's a new car for a nice new car and
all that but that pays itself back over time
yet those are still expenses that are huge and
you know you hit a dry spell with work and you're
like oh god i'm not gonna be able to make rent
now so those are all things that i took from my
experiences over the years and try to work into
it and make it feel authentic you know i i can
see how somebody could easily just tire of
the rat race and just that constant trying
to keep your head above water and just step out
like i'm just i'm gonna go live in the woods
uh i'm gonna go sleep under a bridge i'm
not gonna stress it uh there's actually
there's even a homeless gentleman who slipped
my subway station that every now and then i'd
come home with a bottle of wine or a bottle of
whiskey or something like that and we'd sit on the
bench on the subway platform and just chat and
he was that way he said he just got tired of
trying to survive because he's like this isn't
an easy life but at least i don't have the
i don't have the worries that i had and so
wanted to bring back to it is just that idea of
the struggle just the day-to-day struggle that
so many people face and don't have a way out of
i feel so fortunate that as a filmmaker that i
can go and do a commercial and live off of that
for a month or two or three months and then go
back to my writing and my editing and stuff like
that like that's such a luxury to be able to have
that that most people don't have that ability to
get that magical check that's what the
lottery's you know so popular for um and so
yeah i just wanted to try and express that in
a in a film and show show to people who may be
a little bit more fortunate that it's really easy
for people to to lose their grip and give up hope
we have a quote here from variety about your new
film blood from stone a genre defying vampire film
yes but why hasn't this been done before that's
a good question um it was i this idea had been
fermenting in the back of my head to do kind
of a wacky vampire film but you know we hit the
true blood and twilight years where just vampires
were everywhere and then you have films like what
we do in the shadows that are just i mean perfect
vampire satires it's like okay i can't there's
nothing i can do in that realm that's going to
top that film or even be of any value anymore
um then there's films like uh let the right one in
that are just gorgeous beautiful coming of age art
films that also deal with ideas of immortality
so it was definitely one of those things that
was just kept on the back burner because like
i have nothing of value to bring to this genre
um or to the vampire films and then just
personal experience uh lost uh grandfather
and reflecting on that it was for me it was this
idea of this man who was from another era who
good person in his heart and a good
grandfather but also somebody that after
john wayne stopped making movies and uh you know
cultural and social changes happened with uh
you know us white guys not having all the power
anymore um it wasn't his era anymore and he didn't
like where the world was going he didn't feel like
he belonged here anymore and kind of just gave up
on life but didn't die for 25 years and so i grew
up with his grandfather who just really wasn't
happy with the world i wasn't happy with still
being a part of it and uh started thinking like
that's kind of a fascinating angle on it is this
idea of an immortal somebody who's been here 200
years he comes from the days when he could or
400 years where he could ransack a village and
you know what do you do uh you blame it on
angry gods and you you move on with your
life um what would he do in this new era where
attitudes have changed technology has changed and
um that's what i've jokingly called it uh leaving
las vegas meets natural-born killers because
it's almost there's some parallels the nicholas
cage character and uh leaving las vegas this guy
that's just he's done he's out he's just trying
to numb himself to it all and speed up his exit so
deals with those sorts of ideas and really using
the vampire idea as a way to explore some deeper
themes while it's still being entertaining uh you
know one of my favorite films is samsara which is
kind of about the cyclical nature of existence
and the rise and fall of civilizations and trying
to escape this cycle this perpetual cycle of rise
and fall and creation destruction that we're on um
beautiful film uh but not exactly a uh you
know typical crowd pleaser and so trying
to take themes like that but do it through
the vampire idea of old eras and new eras
uh creation destruction um and the cyclical
nature of things to for characters that have
seen those cycles i've seen a few of them and
it's all kind of repetition to them whereas
to us the daily news is catastrophic to
them they've seen it all and done it all
and so kind of exploring those ideas and that's
where even ideas like i brought in a lot of
iconography and tropes of westerns of newer films
uh films that are thought of as from another era
and showing them in this more modern kind of indie
context where it's gritty and a little rougher
and just contrasting that the music score of being
a blend of synthesizers and rootsy banjo and lap
steel and just showing like these clash different
eras and different genres into this fight between
the old and the new that we see so much of in
our current political and social environment so
that's where i think that genre define
comes from is that it's not a horror film
in the truest sense it's not uh just you know it's
not a romance it's not a western it's not a nor
it's kind of all those in um at least that was the
hope and i've been saying since day one there was
a good chance this film could be a total train
wreck because it's just trying to do a lot of
things at once but so far from initial reactions
it seems to have worked it seems that people are
enjoying it i love the night shoots especially
you had these great shots where maybe the scene
itself was about something very you know violent
but beautiful desert background with a moon
and a cactus and i just wondered how did you pull
that off and what kind of lighting did you use
that was the magic of very recent
technologies uh that was the sony a7 3s
i think that was the model i'm so bad
with the name the number letter combos
which is you know small dslr camera that low-light
capabilities are ridiculous um i was so nervous
when i wrote it i'm like how am i gonna do desert
exteriors with no budget we can't light a desert
um just trying to think of how we could pull
that off and then that camera came out and i
did some tests with it and was like holy crap
i can see a horizon line in the desert at night
and so got a pl mount for it put some
high speed primes on it and we shot
all the car interiors uh with the and from or the
the crazy uh rideshare scene that was all shot on
that thing um all the desert night exteriors
were shot with it and literally no lighting
um just the moon headlights from the car in one of
the shots or actually two of them um and then the
glow of the city from the distance that was our
lighting it was literally just natural light to
be able to pull off night exteriors and then using
some uh neat videos uh denoiser and post to get
rid of the obscene amount of grain in it to pull
off that kind of level of low light um and yeah it
uh it looks awesome i was like pleasantly
surprised with how well those night exteriors
turned out i thought they were gonna be just a
grainy nasty muddy mess but i love how they look
yeah they're beautiful and this is just a small
thing but i noticed three characters wore robes
yes when and it was what was the significance
of that it was almost like the 30 there was
this beautiful even the one that he wears is sort
of sort of more thrift shop style but there was
a very cool sort of theme of these robes thanks
yeah it was uh the rope his robe in it was uh was
intended it was really hard to find a a floral
uh really well used robe that fit vania but uh
we were able it was scripted as basically
the idea is he's supposed to be kind of a
squatter in this home it's obviously not his home
from the decorations to that sort of thing uh
and so that was the idea there and then
with uh with the other two it just kind of
to me it was it's like basically it's a way
to kind of showcase the characters and their
distinct personalities but also they're the like
they're the only three vampires so it's kind
of just it was almost like a uniform in a way
for them like their comfort level um that was
although on a deeper level there really wasn't
anything to the robes it was just kind of i wanted
to show them in their environment their most
like comfortable natural sort of relaxed state
but didn't have like a deeper theme so maybe
there'll be something audiences pull from it i
always i'm always in always enjoy that
when someone says something i'm like
i wish i thought of that i'm going
to use that i was i was really smart
but not with the robes and then the convention
at the bar and sort of this attitude of that
they almost didn't have to behave because
they were out of their element i guess
living in la we see that with a lot of tourists
sometimes you know especially if you're in santa
monica or wherever you can see sort of these
the people that forget that they have to still
engage amongst society and they and they you know
it's like a big fun you know thing and i thought
that was interesting how you showed very subtle
things of these men at this convention and yeah
if you've ever worked a convention or something
maybe i've i worked in uh i was a waiter for
long enough and did enough catering and stuff
like that i've worked some events like that and
to me was so the the three main male characters
and i don't want to give away too many spoilers
here but the three main male characters you have
vania who's just i mean the guy looks like jason
mamoa um this is a giant beast of a man um and
then you have the mic characters the convention
go or then the raymond character the doctor and
to me like the raymond one and the vania and
vania's character yuri they're like the um sort
of like dual lands of male archetypes you have
vania the super alpha male who is all in it for
himself and then the rayman character who is
the much softer more social creature who's
interest introverted and finds his value and how
he can be of benefit to others instead of vanya's
all about how what he can acquire for himself
and with uh the my character the convention
goer he was to me this the guy who by nature
should be more of a raymond but due to social
conditioning and the idea of wanting to be the
alpha macho cool guy he's trying to be more of
the the ure character the the the cool guy that
is suave and handsome and funny and all that and
he fails miserably at it and so it was kind of
um maybe an overused term now but it was kind
of showcasing like the effects of that that
messaging of masculinity and how it's shown in
media and what a guy is supposed to be and sort
of showing how that can become so just ugly um you
know it's like kind of just be true to who you are
i've always you know joked i've never had troubles
with anyone that questions my own masculinity
because i don't have it it's like i just i am
who i am i never wanted to be that alpha guy
and so i kind of wanted to show you know but you
see that in others like when you're trying to be
someone you're not you become a very toxic person
and so like just embrace who you are so that was
kind of that idea of those convention goers
like when they're in that element it's like
he's his character when he's just talking
to daria he's actually a sweet nice guy
when he's with his convention buddies he has to
act like he's the cool alpha dude and so you see
that sort of toxic ugly side of him come out so
that was kind of the idea with exploring it in
that vein and then anyone that's been to you know
the casinos and stuff knows that the conventions
are you know that's half their income i i would
imagine is at least from maybe not the gambling
but definitely from the hotels and stuff like
that is trying to get conventions there and so
anytime you're at a casino there's going to be
a convention there so just kind of part of the
part of the casino life yeah i thought and then
set against the the people gambling the sort of
sad desperation of this jackpot is going to do it
this this last one exactly and same with in the
convention it's all about the sale you know even
when he's sitting there with them they're talking
about acquiring the woman and acquiring the sale
that's literally the the two themes that they they
talk about is uh you know out in the casinos it's
all these people throwing their funds into they're
hoping they get that jackpot and just you know
kind of kind of the idea and uh it was actually
a guy that helped the stunts in it carl he uh uh
came on he's an uh wonderful guy and he said uh
to him it was fascinating when he was there he
goes you almost feel like the vampires are more
alive than the actual living people uh and that
was kind of the idea of it is just showing like
this this constant hunt for some life-sustaining
you know whether it's the the the money from
a jackpot the sale all that like this is like
almost like a vampire culture that has uh you know
kind of become our our uh commercial society jeff
we found this quote from you i think you said i
wanted to create something that people will walk
away from thinking i've never seen anything like
that before a small indie like this can't compete
with hollywood for spectacle and star power but
we can try to make much more interesting films
at least can you expand on that yeah um yeah i
definitely wanted to wanted to make something
that yeah that when people walked away from
they didn't just forget about it uh and
you know if i forget i should remember
i want to see his career brick but they some
director i remember reading years ago said i
don't care if they love it or hate it i want them
to remember it and that to me that's i have more
respect and i enjoy watching films that go for the
gusto and fail over those that just try to appeal
to the most common denominator that's why not a
big fan of superhero movies but i appreciate the
dc ones 100 times over the marvel ones because dc
made some steamers but they're always like they
always try to do something that's really over
the top and interesting or whatever and whereas
marvel like they all kind of bleed together it's
and there's no consequences and you get into
that but even just in the indie film world how do
you compete with those movies i mean they've got
they spend more on uh you know i'm sure their
xerox budget than i had for this whole film
um just to and so you know i'm not gonna allow do
them in action or spectacle and uh star power but
i can at least try and um i can at least try and
give the audience something that they're gonna
walk away feeling like i got a unique experience
from this and so with that like the intent was
not necessarily to make something that's the hard
part about doing that is you don't want to make
something that's uh too um can't think of the word
right now you don't want to make it where it's too
abstract or like audiences aren't gonna feel like
like it's worth committing to it um still make it
entertaining still make it fun you know it's
uh i try to keep it fast-paced a little bit of
a slow burn like it has a slow build but once it
kicks in it's i could try to give it a good pace
there's a lot of just there is some
spectacle in it at least for a small indie
but then thematically i don't like i don't
like things that fit into a neat little box so
uh musicians i like often do a lot of fusion
type of stuff they mix different genres
and same with filmmakers you know some of the
films that inspired me when i was first kind
of getting my start in the night you know
as a teenager in the 90s you know watching
tarantino stuff which is often unclassifiable
for a genre um watching you know uh movies like
california like i guess it's a thriller but
it's also it's funny i mean i still quote that
movie brad pitt's my arguably my favorite
role next to his his role in true romance
um which is another one uh natural born killers
uh some of these films that go dark and they're
like they kind of challenge your own morality
as an audience but at the same time they're
funny they have characters that you fall in love
with uh even though they're horrible and uh um
and just you know deal with deeper human themes
and social and political themes so i kind of fell
in love with movies like that and i feel like we
have an industry that needs to sell things and so
they need to know how to sell it so it needs to
be a certain product and that in a way has really
homogenized so much of storytelling and my own
little way i wanted to try and like break out
of that and not not think about oh well this
is a horror movie so i can't do this or if i
do this um you know fans of the vampire genre are
gonna be like well this isn't a real vampire movie
um and more just let the let the story go where
it needs to go to be the story it needs to be
uh without worrying about making it marketable
now unfortunately for my distributors
makes their job a lot harder it's funny you
mentioned the movie california from was that 1993
yeah that's it okay because the bartender in your
film the opening scenes reminded me of juliet
lewis she had a very similar sort of not just look
but the sort of the character type as well yeah
you know what and uh we that julia lewis character
and julia lewis any movie is one of my favorites
uh she's just phenomenal but in that one
she is she's just i mean phenomenal so
both adorable and trashy and um and i just i
absolutely love her in that movie as well and so
i'm sure on some level like just stylistically
those movies definitely impacted uh you know on
blood from stone i was the uh this wardrobe and
stylist person as well so um you know basically
every article in clothing you see in that i not
only found it purchased or at the very least
agreed to but um yeah so i'm sure my own styling
of the movie was probably heavily inspired by
by that film and that goes back to what you said
too about not everybody wants these like films
that are in a neat little box these popcorn movies
some people want the the juliet lewis protagonist
and and can relate to that more than nothing
against sandra bullock but her characters i admire
sandra's career but her characters are always sort
of very similar and sort of this like savior you
know middle class i'm gonna fix everything
and not all of us can totally relate to that
and again nothing against it but i think it
has to be something a little like there is
a damaged quality to some of juliet's roles and
i yeah i like that well yeah julia lewis always
brings such a vulnerability even in natural
born killers i mean she's ferocious in that
and yet you know the flashbacks to her childhood
the the hostile relationships that she has with
woody harrelson's character um you can understand
where her anger is coming from like it's never
even when she's a monster she plays it in a way
where you still feel some sense of sympathy for
her or at the very least empathy like you're like
i understand why she's acting that way and that
to me i mean that's a that's a great villain and
i also about those movies i mean the villain was
the main characters in those movies um you know
kind of anti-heroes if you want to call them that
and you know there's got to be something
redeeming there was a great quote that said uh
even the devil's convinced himself he's doing the
right thing so you know with any of these you know
villain characters or anti-heroes if you don't
feel like you can understand why they're doing it
then it's not a good character and juliet
lewis is phenomenal at portraying that
did your distributor or indie rights give
you the idea for a vampire movie or that's
something that you came up with and pitched it to
them so um obviously i met you know met michael
linda through frey and indy rights was just
phenomenal for that film uh and has anybody
that's ever gone through distribution knows it's a
nightmare process when you find a good distributor
cling to them and uh um being become good friends
and we're at dinner one night and i was uh
talking with them and i had recently come across
a notepad that had this kind of some notes of
this film so i was telling them about about it
just the initial ideas for it and the next day
michael texted me and basically said this
should be your next film this is something that
could actually sell um and so i started thinking
i was like well you know frey was great and i
mean i'm fortunate it actually made its
budget back and turned mildly profitable
off of you know fairly modest budget but it's
a film i never expected to make a dime off of
but if i want to actually have a career
making films i should probably do one that
has the potential to make money um you
know and so uh so yeah i've decided
uh if i could find a way to make it work for me
that this would be the film to do and that's when
really reflecting on it and finding you know
and it was literally right around the time that
you know story said earlier about
my grandfather passing happened
that i started thinking about it from that
perspective and like okay this could actually
be really interesting um you know just feeling
something that's like you know drinks to numb the
pain it's done with their life but isn't you know
can't die um and then on the the female side of it
um it almost sounds terrible i'm bringing up
family as inspirations for my vampire movie
they're lovely people but my mother had said to me
years ago when she was growing up she was you know
in the 60s being raised to be like you know good
housewife if she had aspirations it was to be a
teacher or a secretary and then you know late 60s
uh women's rights and really started to flourish
and she's like when i went off to college all of
a sudden being told i can be anything i want to
be and like i never thought of that before
who i don't even know who i want to be and
she's a i could go on forever she's an amazingly
talented and smart woman who just it took really
until later on in life before she found
the things he's really passionate about
um and by that time it was like well i can't
really make this my career i'm in my you know
late 50s or 60s so um it was kind of the
idea of like exploring that a woman who's
from that type of whether culture or an era
where they were really a commodity that if
they wanted to be something it was to be
a housewife and a kind of a servant class
how does someone like that navigate and find her
own agency in this current climate where women are
finally allowed to have a voice finally allowed to
make those decisions that can guide their life and
whether those decisions are right or wrong i
mean the character in the script makes some dumb
decisions um some decisions that she regrets uh
but she had the the agency and the freedom to make
those choices and that's part of her coming of her
own you know into her own and coming out of this
uh this sort of uh place where she'd been under
yuri or been a you know villager and being able
to kind of find that navigate that but then also
learning from the examples around her you know her
her colleague and friend is another you know
cocktail waitress who maybe isn't the best example
of how to you know make the right decisions in
your life and so kind of explores that idea and
gabriella who plays daria was just such a perfect
discovery for somebody to really encapsulate that
persona authentically she was excellent is she
eastern european because she had a beautiful
accent but i looked at her bio it didn't say yeah
she's actually hungarian uh she grew up in hungary
and she's been in the u.s for a while now but
uh it was actually coincidentally i didn't know
this until after i'd cast her i was talking about
some of the inspirations for when i was writing
the family i based it loosely off the uh elizabeth
bathory and her family uh she's like infamous uh
often believed to have been a real vampire and
found out that gabriella actually grew up about
approximately 10 miles from their castle so
probably you know sure ancestors of hers had been
uh you know sacrifices to the bathrooms back in
the day so or at least had known them so it's uh i
think she she brought a lot of that heritage that
a really authentic heritage to the character um
and also you know coming from a country that
politically and socially is very different
than ours um you know something i always
thought about with my grandmother who was uh
she was also from eastern europe and even you know
all these all those years later still like a very
reserved woman a very thoughtful strong woman
but very reserved in her ways like almost i mean
almost that old idea of knowing a woman's place
like she was very much of that you know for
someone coming from a different culture where
that is still a thing um that a woman has a place
having that in this character
having that be something that she's
actively trying to grow beyond
but still struggling with that
you know i think gabby's had this naturalness
with that because she's coming from a place
that kind of still has some of those old
world social structures and philosophies
yeah i thought she played the part extremely
well and you'd also see it in her eyes
she'd be processing something but wouldn't
necessarily say it so you could tell okay she'll
play the role but she's got another trick up her
sleeve and and yeah i like that too i thought that
was really well done that was a huge challenge for
her and something i knew early on was going to be
a difficult thing for anyone that played that
roles throughout the entire film there's only two
scenes where you see her authentic self or three
scenes i should say uh where you see her authentic
self for most of the movie her overt emotions are
a cover for what the character is actually feeling
and so she really had to play that well and
um a few of the people have seen it the film
more than once have said it's interesting
to watch it that second time where you can
really see how she does you know
ride that line of like showing acting
the emotions that her character is supposed to
be acting but also showing what the character is
really feeling and like you said so much of it is
through just her incredibly subtle mannerisms her
eyes um just very gifted actress absolutely and i
i noticed she she should have more credits i hope
she gets more work i looked at her imdb and i
really hope she gets more roles because she's
so talented we're actually nervous about that
with both her and uh vanya for leads in a film
uh nika who was so helpful in the
film as well is a supporting role
uh she and i had some talks about that in terms
like are we really entrusting in this film to
some actors that don't have a lot of credits i
mean bonnie had the theater background at least
but you'd watch the tapes and he's like i just
i believed them so much and uh you know really
glad i took that you know had that faith
in them and they had the faith in me to
you know go off to vegas for a month into this
crazy shoot um but yeah i got really fortunate
with them they're both uh just phenomenal talents
and i too really hope to see them a lot more
i was joking i hope by the time we do
the sequel to this i can't afford them
we have a quote here from your executive
producer and distributor michael madison
and he's of indie rights and he put jeff
ryan proved that he could deliver the
highest quality production value and dramatic
flair on a budget that makes profitability much
more attainable than more directors can deliver
so your first your first feature frey reached
what the top 15 in amazon war films yeah
yeah warren military yeah frey reached uh
it reached the top 15 war and military films in
amazon the u.s and it got to number two under
art house independent films in the uk um they
apparently don't have uh warren military section
so they put it under in the art house but uh it
was wild i mean i just never expected that i mean
we were literally right below i have a screenshot
of it we were right below apocalypse now like if
we if i go above apocalypse now on amazon i'm
just going to retire i'm never going to top that
just go out while you're ahead um it was wild
i mean to see our little film up do performing
better than you know on amazon performing better
than uh hurt locker performing better than
you know platoon these films that were just to
me iconic uh and great films uh in in their own
right uh and i mean the uk one also have
screen grabbed because it was just surreal
to see it was literally the only film above it was
reservoir dogs uh wow which is just wild to see uh
so yeah and again i mean we did that
film for so little um there's a lot
of expenses to the film that add up i mean
the festival circuit marketing promotion
sound mastery and i spent a fortune on on fray
i was also a director sound man and i'm not a
great sound man so a lot of post budget on uh
refining the sound quality and stuff like that
um but uh but yeah it was great to see that
happen and so you know linda and michael
not only because of that but they've seen what
i've done with the commercial world they've seen
you know just the diversity of projects
i can do that have been successful for
clients so they know that even though frey is
my only was my only feature at the time that
i at least had the consistency be able to deliver
at a high production value for modest budgets
and so and again i'm just i'm fortunate the fact
that i fell into the world of doing like you know
fashion web commercials and stuff where you know i
wouldn't have the greatest budget for my end of it
but would make it work and just got to constantly
be shooting i mean they have a new season every
three months so there'll be a new ad every three
months and i was really fortunate constantly
refining that skill set and then not having
budgets always having to get my own costumes
do my own set design but learning from these
commercial shoots from working with these you know
professional production designers professional
costume designers and all sorts of stuff and so i
developed taste level for what you can
accomplish with a budget but then also um
try to apply that to my own productions where you
know and i i enjoy that stuff i think that's part
of having that fine arts background helps
where it's not about the medium it's about
the overall message in the writing and development
process what kinds of questions were you asking
yourself about the story about the characters
um in my writing process i actually i have a
weird process i've read this book uh called the
mind of the maker by dorothy l sayers and it's
a fascinating book i recommend to anybody in the
creative field she wrote in 19 1941 it came out
and she was a mystery writer but she wrote this
one it was about she's trying to write a book of
theology but in trying to explain the mind of of
a god she uses artists and writers as an example
and it's a one of the things i loved
about it is she said that as a creator
you create the world you create the physics of it
and the laws of it and you create the people that
inhabit it but then you give them free will and to
me that is the most organic form of writing and so
my writing process is i try to i try to
just see the world and try to understand
it and know who my characters are and the
premise and then i literally just i ferment
on that for a while until i feel like i would
understand i'll write notes and stuff like that
and then i literally just sit down and write
and just when it comes to a plot point like what
would they do here what would they do here and
letting the character i've conjured my mind have
that free will to make those choices instead
of me guiding them the only time i feel like
i hit a writer's block now is when i'm trying
to force them to do something they wouldn't do
and so that is kind of my writing process and
then once i have a first draft out that's when
i then go back and start asking myself those
questions like okay here's some of the themes
i wanted to address that maybe aren't as clear
or in it how do i put that into it how do i
is there a way place where this works is there
a place where this works and so i have a kind
of a weird writing style i developed after reading
that book and it was to me was a lifesaver because
that's why fray ended up being the film it is was
i completely after reading that i changed my whole
creative style and writing style based on what i'd
read in there and it obviously worked with frey
so i decided to keep doing it that way and you
know i think that's part of why blood from stone
is so different as well is i don't set up a
structure i don't set up markers i don't have
any plot points i write down it's like here's the
world here's the characters let's see where we go
and i actually like the process now i can like
fray i wrote in about three weeks beginning
to end and the first draft of the final
draft there's a lot of editing a lot of
refining but as a whole they're very similar and
same with blood from stone uh if you look at the
first draft in the final draft other than chopping
a lot of pages off of it it's a very similar story
uh so for better for worse the writing
style that works for me we'll see what
audiences feel but i enjoy it i comes out much
more organically i don't get writer's block
it just takes a lot longer to write that first
page because you're trying to figure out all
the aspects of the world that they're in all the
people that are there but once you have that all
just kind of let them loose in your brain and see
what happens that's how i do it at least how did
you find that book or how did the book find you it
sounds like that sounds like a very magical book
i haven't actually heard of it it's yeah i found
it i one of my obsessions is i collect old books
uh not like collectible old books i only have a
few of those um but just i love going into antique
stores thrift stores old bookstores and digging
through for just ones that sound interesting and
i'm obsessed with reading about psychology i'm
obsessed with reading about religion and theology
i'm obsessed with reading about other cultures
um and uh anthropology and all that sort of stuff
and i just i was going through one of those
sections there was a book called the mind of
the maker i'm like well that sounds fascinating
and i read just the first two pages of her of
dorothy's uh introduction and i was laughing like
it is hilarious she the first two pages of it are
just brilliant it goes on i mean throughout it
she's actually funny she has an entire chapter
i really feel like it was devoted to
just trashy and another author she hated
every time she is using examples of creative
blasphemy she references his work and just
trashes him she's absolutely hilarious in the
book it's a really thoughtful book a really
heavy book it's also a motivating one because
she wrote it during world war ii and twice in
the book she briefly references getting back to
writing after a bombing raid and i think back
to that whenever i've had a bad day and i just
don't feel like being creative i'm like she wrote
one of my favorite books while being bombed
by nazis i can get over my bad day and write
so it's just all around i highly recommend
that book if you can track it down
i could also see inside of you that maybe if you
don't have a chance to be creative that could also
drive you you know very that you need to create i
get that sense that you need to always be creating
something not just in client work but for yourself
yeah definitely always have to be creating um
i said uh uh i always say that i've been saying
for a long time that my career wasn't a um you
know being a filmmaker wasn't a career choice
the way of coping with my own uh mental health
issues uh and it really is i mean whether it was
as a little kid drawing on the walls to get into
animation constantly writing little stories it
was just always a really a big part of who i was
you know friends that would play like dungeons and
dragons instead of playing those games i would be
drawing their stories and making picture books
of them or that type of thing and just always
in that that realm of thinking so it is
a very natural part of just life and i've
had jobs where i couldn't be creative and
then i would get home in the evenings and
i mean jared and i were roommates who were broke
we couldn't afford anything but i had some acrylic
paints and we had a couple cereal boxes we started
painting cereal boxes and uh we by the time we
left our apartment we had over 60 cereal boxes
on the walks we couldn't afford canvases but we
painted cereal boxes um things like that that
uh just it is it's something you have to do and
the beauty of it is when i was in
high school that short film i did
uh i had a magical moment i got a letter
you know this is before emails i got a
letter from somebody who had seen the film and
she wrote to me the film was about censorship
and she wrote to me about how it impacted her
thoughts on it and changed her way of of seeing
this the uh the debate over censorship that was
going on around that era of around the era of
natural-born killers and true romance and gangster
rap and all that stuff they were trying to ban um
and as uh you know 17 year old me getting this
letter from somebody realizing that my movie had
changed their mind about something that core to
our values as a as a people um i was like well
what else could i ever want to do with my life um
and you know it took me 17 years to make fray and
for that to come out and then to be able to get
letters from people have seen it to see tears
in people's eyes afterwards about talking about
how it made them feel better about themselves
or understand their family member better um
yeah it's just to me you know if i wasn't doing
the creative part is great i love that and i
would always do that but then to be able to use it
to try and put some kind of good into the world
uh which there's not a lot of so it's like put
some good into the world make people feel like
they understand each other better make people
feel like we're in this together um and like
what else could you ever hope to accomplish as a
um so to me that's what motivates me to keep going
and keep doing my own films because you know if
somebody else is pain i might not be able to get
away with some of the themes i deal with and that
type of thing if you're answering to somebody you
tend to self-censor and by the way i i should have
rephrased i didn't mean that you would go crazy
not doing art but that it seems like that would be
something more in your wheelhouse than going
to the mall oh yeah oh totally that's how i
should have probably phrased it but i appreciate
how you how you added that yeah yeah no i mean
i i call my apartment my cave because it's i don't
i don't like to leave it and um yeah i'm just much
happier when i'm just making stuff or at least
at the very least honestly just sitting back and
contemplating reading about other reading other
people's books um you know reading about other
lives other ideas reading about philosophy or
all that sort of stuff like i'd rather be in that
world trying to understand the world than being
a part of the world being a part of the world
is not my favorite thing trying
to understand it i love doing
that makes sense especially now yeah what are some
big revelations you've had or the biggest success
you've had when developing this story about
blood from stone the big success i mean the
film hasn't come out yet so i'm really curious to
see how people interpret it because again it's uh
it's a weird film it's not a weird film in like
the most uh overt way it's not something like
you know like the lighthouse which is such
a beautiful brilliant film it's also very
obviously like you you know going to that it's a
different movie um this one is a little bit more
subtle and how it's weird so i'm curious
how people are going to respond to it but
for me personally i don't know about like a
revelatory but the thing i'm the proudest of
on a very personal level it was the first feature
i've ever i've been the cinematographer on
um as well and it had a very complicated visual
language addisola who's here with me he and i
really sat down like shot listed and storyboarded
this whole thing um because every shot in it
or every scene really is like they're they
overlap and they weave and a lot of the visual
dynamics of it um communicate between scenes
something you know the way a shot is composed
in one scene speaks to how something's composed
in another what you're seeing in one storyline is
complemented or contrasted in another storyline
and the way they story lines in our weave
if i butchered some shots if they didn't turn in
if i didn't get them the way that i'd intended uh
the film would have completely fallen apart at the
seams uh so much of the juxtaposition between the
the interwoven storylines really is what makes
some of the dramatic aspects of the film work
and even some of the themes really work
uh and so when we got a final edit of it
and i was watching it back i'm like this is
absolute insanity and i can't believe it worked
um you know there's almost no establishing
shots in the whole movie there's i think
five establishing shots in the whole film maybe
four um you know we closed down main street in las
vegas and had cop cars and all sorts of stuff and
the entire thing is done other than two shots the
entire thing's done on a very tight lens where
you only are focused on the one character even
though there's all this chaos going on around
him um just things like that that visually were
um against the grain like not how i
would how not how you're supposed to
shoot a scene not how you're supposed to you
know cover it and dissect it and all that
and just believing that what i was seeing
in my head was actually going to work
um and then coming out on the other side and
like oh it actually did you know is it the
most cinematically masterful film ever made no um
but as a visual language to do something so off
kilter and actually have it succeed i'm quite
excited about how did you go about developing
these vampire characters i've kind of have
parts of myself in all of them uh like you
know vania of the year you know his performance
as europe he brought to a whole other level
but there's that part of me that's just impulsive
and very much about like just living in the moment
um doing things you regret not understanding why
you know you have you're perceived a certain way
all that sort of stuff um darya's character
again deal with a lot of that deal with you
know kind of my own like self-repression uh
as well so it's a lot like in a way there's
so much of me and all the characters uh and that's
i think that's just essential it's like there's a
line that's told to every writer and
it's a dangerous one where they say
write what you know and too often times i find
that makes writers kind of go with most obvious
like well i await tables so my character is
going to be a waiter who wants to be a filmmaker
it's like no not necessarily that but put what you
know into your characters like create something
fantastical if you want but put yourself into
those characters put people that you know
into those characters so that way when you're
writing them they feel authentic they feel real
um especially for for myself like who
who needs to see another movie about some
average white guy who wants to get the girl and
you know ends up succeeding in the end or not
or whatever it's like that story's been told
a hundred times i don't even want to watch a
movie about my life so in terms of that like being
able to find something interesting about the life
i've had about my own persona and put that into
my characters and then you know then from there
just have fun with it okay here's my character now
set them free what are they gonna do once they're
out in the world um you know what's yuri gonna do
when he's in a he's in a in an uber ride chair and
some drunk people get in next to him and they're
obnoxious me i would be quiet and ignore them
his character he's a beast and he's a vampire so
he kills them um then he feels bad for the driver
who's now stuck in the situation and now how does
he handle that well you know and so just kind of
for me it's like i like to create the characters
put them in a scenario and see where they go
what are your thoughts on writing a protagonist
that's a villain uh i mean i really feel like
any protagonist if they're authentic is also going
to be a villain everybody's got that side to him
and i hopefully i'm not just projecting
myself out there by saying that uh
but um to me it's not a i don't i don't even
like the idea of having villains having like
protagonist antagonists because it's really it's
all about perspective you know you flip the lens
around and you know the bad guy is actually he's
doing what he feels is the right thing to do in
his mind he's justified it's why you know you go
back in history you look at nazi propaganda films
they didn't shoot them intending hitler to look
like the villain but us looking back at it now
it's very iconic villain imagery you see it
in the new star wars films you see in so many
movies they take that imagery and they flip
it around that was obviously not the intent
of those films and so any character if you write a
really fleshed out character i mean even on i mean
the nazi thing is a big scale on a personal scale
we've all been in relationships you had a fight
with your significant other you know you're right
until a certain part of the argument where you're
like oh no you just made a really good point no
okay i'm in the wrong on that so even in that
argument like you went into it you were the hero
and then you ended with like oh no i'm the villain
uh so that's how i approach my characters is not
thinking who's the good guy who's the bad guy
who's the you know who's the one i'm rooting
for in the end it's just let's get to know them
let's see who they are and let the audience decide
who they think is like one of my favorite things
and i don't want to spoil too much for those who
haven't seen it but one of my favorite things is
daria's character she starts out she's very
much the damsel in distress type of trope she's
you know the ex-girlfriend
escaped an abusive relationship
she's with the sky that we've all seen him be
a monster and then the story makes a turn and
you start realizing she's not as helpless as i
thought she was how much of a victim is she really
and then you see that she's even reconciling
that of who she wants to be versus who she is
and to me that's so much more interesting than
being oh she's good and he's bad uh i just i feel
like that's where so many movies become so cookie
cutter and so boring is when it's so obvious who
who's who in the film by i want it to be by the
end of the film you're still trying to figure out
wait who was i supposed to be rooting for like
i'm happy how i ended but why am i happy they
were terrible or um you know kind of wanting to
know more like if i feel like if a movie ends
and you're you're trying to peace out in your
mind where this character went and what they did
and you're still thinking about the decisions
they made then that's that's a successful film
because it makes you feel like that world was real
and you cared about those characters you found
them interesting enough to contemplate how was it
writing two female characters one of them actually
had very masculine qualities to her though yeah
in the typical stereotype she was very strong
and was actually lifting him up well she's the
older sister and i have a very strong older sister
she was always the boss growing up and even
to this day we still kind of have that fun uh
you know we have fun with it now but still have
that and so writing the older sister role in the
film was easy because um you know and honestly
like there's a lot of strong women in my family
lineage even going back i mean uh an aunt on my
mother's side was a postal carrier in alaska back
when she had to get around on a dog sled in the
early 1900's oh wow long lineage of strong women
um you know great-grandmother raised her kids
as a single mother during the great depression
my grandmother on my mom's side was uh you know
a working woman in the 50s and stuff like that um
and so just strong women to me that's like
that's just how they should be written um
and uh and then just in my life i've i've been
one of those guys that's always had a circle of
female friends i actually enjoy them as human
beings and as equals and so knowing know
them on that personal level and not just
seeing them as relationship or conquest
and so to me that it uh even when i'm writing them
there's obviously gender differences in terms of
how they're the the specific experiences that
they have throughout the film there's going to
be that but i don't approach it like writing oh
this is a woman character to me i'm just writing
a character that happens to be a woman my
favorite author of all time janette winterson she
she once in an interview was asked how it feels
to be such a well-respected lesbian author
and she retorted back she's like i'm not a lesbian
author i'm an author who happens to like women
i feel like from the writing perspective
that's how i should treat my characters is yes
we all have aspects of our gender and race and all
that that does affect our our uh specifics uh in
life in a lot of ways but in the end i at least
i want to believe that we're all human beings and
uh should when i write them i write different
characters in that way with an awareness of you
know whatever differences that they may have from
myself but not trying to make that their defining
character trait does that make sense it does did
you like a lot of female characters in film noir
oh yeah because they were quite strong and at
times conniving and clever definitely i mean
definitely in classic films it was interesting
because you know we think that era we think very
defined gender roles but uh in classic films and
he had catherine hepburn and bringing up baby is
one of my favorite performances of all time
she's just phenomenal in that in a powerhouse
uh you know so there's so many great ones out
there angela bassett was one of my big favorites
in strange days when i saw her in that and just
how incredible she was than that when i was you
know i was in the 90s but just such a phenomenal
performance you have just so many strong great
performances by female actresses you know
we were mentioning julia lewis earlier uh
yeah i just think being able to bring that into
a film you know there's a lot of talk about that
right now in terms like social justice and all
that it's always been there it's just been as
it's not been as common as it should be um but
i don't think it's doing anything new it's not
it's not changing anything it's just you know to
a certain extent maybe just a reflection of uh
of our current selves or you know others
people that created it like for myself
obviously i said strong women are a natural part
of my life i'm gonna have that in my stories
um others just haven't had that in you know maybe
that's why you don't see it as much in other films
but it's not like an active choice
i make it's just how they come out
what does story structure mean to you story
structure for me is uh it's essential and yet at
the same time i i try to ignore it if that makes
sense it's i mean you know with all the stuff i've
talked a bit about kind of like going to defy
conventions or whatever but i also do believe
that as an artist if you don't understand what
those conventions are what the structures are
then you're not defining them you just don't know
what you're doing if you don't follow them and so
i really did spend you know read about it a lot
and i've you know studied in terms like story
structure and the you know the three act the fire
back structure all that type of stuff there's such
a value to it i mean even if it's not obvious that
it's there in a lot of films it should kind of be
there and so i do follow that like this one i feel
like has like the traditional five act structure
just in a very loose way um and it's just you know
if you don't hit certain plot points by certain
points you're gonna bore your audience uh you know
it's one thing to challenge an audience and to ask
them to really commit themselves to your story
it's another to you know force them to you know
wait forever for something to happen or to not
give them something to cling on to narratively
so i do try to keep the audience's interest and
attention at my in their in my mind when i'm
maybe not the first draft but as i'm editing and
refining the script i like to keep that audience
uh perspective in mind like okay they have
to watch this so let me think about them now
uh and so that's where i think knowing
structure really comes into play is just knowing
the best way to reach those beats hit those
moments uh i did say earlier though i'm
not a big fan of character arcs at least not
obvious ones because i feel like in real life
unless something traumatic happens to you you
don't actually change you just adjust or um
so for me instead of worrying about a character
arc like well he starts here and he ends this
person or he finds this out of himself and changes
here i kind of like to create a personality type
and a psychology and then put them into a
situation like okay now how do they cope with this
what is that's kind of more how we are in real
life is you know i am who i am if you put me in
a burning building i'm not going to suddenly
turn into a hero i'm probably going to flee
um you know what circumstances would it take for
me to become that hero um it would have to be
for a loved one uh my cats depending on the day
maybe i would risk it uh but you know that's to
me is the interesting thing is not necessarily
like hitting the ark in the traditional way but
setting those plot points of like okay at this
point this character has this happened to him and
he does this and then at this point he realizes
oh this all backfired and then it you know so
that's kind of how i like to follow the
structure like you have those points but
in terms like so much of the traditional
writing on story structure and everything
i'm not a fan of a lot of the guidance
on how his stories should develop
you know obviously there's some very very
successful filmmakers that have followed those
formulas and done quite well with it so you know
take my my opinion on it for what it's worth um on
my second film we'll see how it do how it does so
but that's at least how i approach it personally
how long did you work on the
screenplay it's debatable i mean
i literally had my first notes written down
when i was in high school so a few decades
um uh it went through various different forms
and then i would get discouraged because
again what am i bringing to the vampire
genre that's worth the damn um and then
uh when i really when the when it clicked
for me like oh this is a story i want to tell
i started fermenting on it right a little bit
here and there and after about four months of just
kind of letting it still in my brain and writing
some notes here and there and some thoughts and
another thing i do is because i read a lot i have
a little black book of quotes that i keep of just
lines i'm like this because so many authors can
say something in one throwaway line that would
take me an entire essay to express so i like to
write those down and just keep those and so i
kind of like picked my quotes that capture the
essence the story i want to tell then sat down
and wrote it in the first draft i literally
had it in three weeks and then i sent it to
no actually i revised that one i sent the second
draft to a few friends get some feedback some
notes um and then reworked it over the course of
about six months and then started up on production
so when you were in high school where were
you writing were like was this during like
class break or something and you're like
writing on a composite you know like
tear out sheet yeah during class
sometimes i was not the best student
the fact i made through high school was
only thanks to the graciousness of some
teachers who believed i had potential
if i just learned how to put the work in
i'm still grateful for them because that really
is what it comes down to is it doesn't matter
how talented you are if you don't put the
work in nobody's going to see your talent
so getting those f's in high school was a
valuable learning experience um but yeah i
was i would draw and write during class after
class i'd go home and had a cave then that i
made and i would be in my little cave drawing and
writing and just constantly coming up with ideas
most of them looking back garbage i was not
a prodigy i was definitely still developing
a voice but yeah i just loved it i absolutely
loved just creating little worlds or stories or
ideas and imagining them uh and even to this day
i mean that's you'll half time you'll find me on
my patio with a book in hand reading something
or just contemplating ideas themes whatever
it's kind of my favorite way to pass the time
what tv shows did you watch when you were in
high school oh i have terrible taste in tv uh
let's see what would be in high school actually
oddly enough in high school i wasn't watching a
lot of tv i watched more movies then but i was
obsessed with animation i'm still an animation
junkie i watched south park religiously um
but back then i mean i was watching again
some older was like animaniacs i was
watching every afternoon after school loved
that show still one of the all-time greats
so i was watching that watching old still
obsessed but definitely back then i was
obsessed with the old uh warner brothers and
hannah barbera cartoons from tom and jerry
to bugs bunny and all that stuff loved all those
classics tech savory cartoons which uh problematic
by today's standards but i loved them back then
uh you know yeah i was a true animation junkie for
and then i've always been a news junkie
too i watched the news almost every night
um you know during my high school years were uh
some pretty you know for me defining moments in uh
kind of the way i saw our society and our you know
authority and stuff like that with um you know we
had the uh the branch davidians in waco when i
was you know just entering my teens and you had
the columbine shootings and you know i mean i had
made some films up at that point in my in my high
school with friends where there were guns involved
in stuff like that in the in you know fake guns
but i was doing that and then the columbine thing
happened and just everything changed um and so
uh yeah but that to me was uh what i watched i
would go between cartoons and then the serious
stuff i'm still kind of that way like i've seen
all the fast and furious films and then i'll go
watch some art house and then i'll read the news
so what screenwriting mistakes have you made
in your earlier work that you've corrected oh so
many mistakes in my early work uh the biggest one
and it still survives in a short film that i made
uh was monologues oh my god i used to write some
obscenely long pretentious monologues as you can
probably tell i've very opinionated about things
you know kind of philosophical about things and
i would put way too much that into my characters
and it was annoying and i feel bad for the actors
i had to try and deliver those things um that was
the big one learning to you know the obvious thing
show not tell that was hard for me it really took
trusting my own abilities as a filmmaker trusting
the audience as another big part of it you know
we've all got this idea that because fast
nefarious is so popular because kind of
derivative films are so popular that audiences
aren't smart they are smart just sometimes they
want to turn their brain off but if you're making
a film that allow that encourages them to turn
their brain on they'll go just as deep as you
want them to go and so that to me was a big
part of it is learning to write better for sure
learning to write smarter but then also trusting
that i don't have to explain everything to the
audience that they can figure it out and that
just that took time and experience you know going
to festivals and seeing how audiences responded to
my films seeing how they responded other films
and just you know learning to trust both myself
and audiences was the biggest change for me
and not being so on the nose about my writing
has overriding ever been an issue for you i know
you talked about you had these characters with
these monologues and their opinions and
things but in terms of the actual story
has overriding ever been an issue for you um i
haven't done that much overwriting uh blood from
stone i've definitely chopped a good chunk of it
off i mean i already knew the film that i had in
my mind was not going to be a 90 minute film it
was going to be i was assuming at least 145 150
maybe even 155 the fact it's over two hours uh
my distributors weren't happy about that but
upon seeing it they're like it works it's tight
it's a tight two hour and four minute movie but um
even with that the script itself did have
some and it was really that it's still
my natural go too is i'm going to write it down
and then so i had a lot of dialogue that was way
too long you know i'm sure you noticed there's the
scene of the brother and sister in the bar talking
that goes on for a little while i love it
a few people love it some say it's too long
i left it in um i think the actors did great
with it so i i enjoyed on that level um
but yeah i do find myself doing that and i
often times my first draft and my second draft
maybe first a third draft there's at least a
ten page difference of how much i've cut out
uh frey was the only one that wasn't that way
frey was just a very short succinct script
the actual script for that is just over 60
pages um it was a very short succinct one
so and was a lot of the dialogue improv no
it was just that film has so many scenes
of i mean there's only so many ways you can
write he looks off in the distance depressed
and you know but when you're shooting it and
you have brian's phenomenal performance with
jaron's amazing cinematography that one line
is a minute or two minutes of the film and
it's an incredibly powerful minute or two minutes
because of the visuals and the performance in it
but because i wasn't trying to sell the script i
wasn't trying to impress anybody with the script
it was literally going to be read by our team i
didn't embellish with a bunch of descriptions or
anything like that i was just like you know the
character's name is justin like justin walks to
uh you know the job interview he you know then
i write the job interview dialogue and then
he walks home i wouldn't you know embellish
and all that because i had it in my head i
knew jaren was going to make it look great i
knew brian was going to kill it as a performer
so wrote a really lazy script for that
one probably not the best thing to say
to inspire people to get really
good at being professional writers
but because like i said i wasn't trying to sell
it i wasn't trying to impress anybody with it
i just wrote it for me and my little crew so
that's why that one i got away with being lazy
i think that's it kind of says a lot in that that
you weren't really writing for the market yeah you
weren't writing to impress whomever it was just
a story that you really want to tell you had a
family member that experienced this you'd met
people and that's where a lot of that came from
it was wild too because uh when it came out and
we got the good reviews of that i got an email
one day from the academy of motion pictures of
arts and sciences and they requested a copy of
the script for their permanent library which was
amazing and i was like i'm kind of embarrassed
to say give them this script it's like you know
let me at least create a proper title page for it
um and uh yeah so it was kind of wild that like
probably my laziest script so far has been my most
successful so i don't know what that says about
me as a writer maybe i just shouldn't try so hard
or that's just the story that you're writing and
how connected you i think that's a big part of
it is really like the story and that one just
there was so much of my own you know i told you
about the research i did getting to know so
many people who were living that life my own
cousin's experiences it kind of just that one just
flowed out and i had a very specific idea for it
so um i think that's kind of key in writing is
you know really know what you're writing have a
have a like really believe it and
just trust it as you're writing it
how do you work with actors i have
a great time working with actors and
pretty much all the actors i've worked
with still like me so that's a good sign
i when i'm working with actors i really try to
focus on the early stages one is just getting them
to feel comfortable with me because they're
putting a lot of faith in me as a director
uh that i'm going to steer them in the right
direction that i know what i'm talking about uh
you know every actor especially you
know um people are starting out or
that do a lot of supporting work so many of them
get thrown into these just terrible movies where
they're almost ashamed they were part of it um
and so they're putting a lot of faith in me as
a director and as a writer that you know that i'm
going to deliver for them and so kind of get them
comfortable let them know kind of my vision who
i see their character as what i see it saying
all that but then i work with
them to feel really comfortable
with their understanding of the character even
before we get into lines um really talking with
them who did they see their character as what
is you know when the character does this in a
scene do you have any questions about that or is
there any questions you have about your character
um i really want them to feel like they know
that person and that therefore when they're
playing them they're not they're not thinking
about notes they had there's nothing worse i mean
there's a lot of actors process and each of
them has their own process someone write a very
complicated chart that tracks their character's
arc and their choices throughout the whole film
which is great because you want you know
if that's how they do it you want them to
feel like they know their character and they
understand it they can see the whole thing
but the last thing you want to see is
when they're performing you don't want
to see them thinking about those notes you
want them to be living in the moment and so
getting to the point where they trust they
know the character that's when i know i have
i have a good performance once we get to that
stage i start feeling really good about it
you know when we're doing fray brian uh we walked
worked on his walk for days getting his walk down
to where you could see that he had the physical
wound but you can also see he was trying to hide
it um him spending that time with those uh
those veterans was a huge breakthrough for
him it changed his his own personal perspective
on it he actually said to me after that he said
because i was really excited about this
movie because it's an incredible role and i
you know really feel like it's a great opportunity
for me as an actor but after meeting these guys
he's like i all i can think about now is
i just hope i can do their story justice
and that to me was when it changed it became for
him it wasn't about playing a role it became real
to him uh he saw the lives that those guys had and
obviously i couldn't do that with the vampire film
but part of it with them was you know the casting
vania's from serbia gabby's from hungary uh
and so they come from the worlds
of these vampires are from
they had that folklore and stuff growing
up so i was a big part of it already
naturally their accent is there so we have
to come up with some cheesy dracula accent
but then helping them understand and find those
connections that they have to them personally
and then from there creating onset an
environment where they feel safe to take risks
to not feel like if they flub a line
that i'm going to be upset with them and
for vania part of it he's an amazing talent but
english isn't his first language uh you know he
struggled with some of my dialogues to let allow
him the freedom to make it his own and some of his
improv in it and some of the lines he came up with
was so much better than what i wrote uh he has
some throwaway lines that i up that still make me
laugh and i've seen the film a thousand times now
uh so allowing them to really personalize it
and make it themselves and not feeling like as
the writer director that i'm losing my vision
because they're taking something in a new way
it's almost like okay let's go for this
ride let's see where they take me now
uh and i just find like that just helps it's
again it's empowering to them keeps them from
feeling like they're walking on eggshells
that you know worrying about making a mistake
um but then also not being afraid to correct
them if something's really you know the choice
isn't right having that conversation
catching them early on it feeling like
you know again if you have that trust they're
going to respect when i speak up and i'm like
no that's not how how your character would go we
can have that discussion they can understand why
um had that with vania i had that with gabby
had that with brian have had that with all my
actors where you have that moment where it's like
you know it's great i like what you were trying
to do there but let's think about it from this
perspective of why your character wouldn't do that
and i always say if i can't justify
a choice it's not the right choice
so with any actor i always have that justification
otherwise let them do it their way if i'm going to
give them a note there's going to be a reason
for it otherwise i want them to feel like
they've got it what are the pros and cons of
working with non-actors you know when you see
movies sometimes let's say winners bone where
you're like you know what those are real people
it seems like for the most part in the background
and it really lends to the film and just from
watching the trailer of fray i think you had said
that there were non-actors in it but i i could
it really made me feel like i was there in a town
a small town logging area it's for for any film i
think it's it can be great if you want to if you
want to have authenticity just use the real people
uh it makes a world of difference because
you know great character actors can embody
interesting characters for sure but there is
still something different from an actor playing
somebody like that versus the real person
that's their life and that's what they do um
so authenticity is the greatest attribute
of it um for a low-budget film you know
there's no way on a movie like that i was able
to cast and afford uh 30 great extras or with or
you know supporting roles stuff like that like
i can only bring on so many people and i would
rather have somebody who's real and maybe not the
best actor versus a bad actor who's not real um
you know if you threw like the uh there's a scene
where he's interviewing for a job at a dairy queen
and becky was the actual manager of that dairy
queen who just does the scene in the interview now
she just had to be herself she was doing an actual
job interview it just happened to be on camera
and she was nervous and everything but
we got her comfortable and she did it and
and with non-actors i don't give them
dialogue i give them point a and point b
now just be you and then the actor you know brian
was great at impro improv so he could go with it
he could roll with it he knew things he had
to get across so he would steer it that way
so that's part of having a very talented actor to
work with that can steer a scene like that with
becky i was like okay you're interviewing him he's
got to have these qualifications you've got to ask
him about this and then just do a normal interview
and then trust also that you can pull it off in
editing and make it work so that was a big thing
and one of my favorite moments from that was when
la weekly put out the review they ended the review
quoting becky she actually had a line in that
that when when she said it i was just like that's
better than anything i will ever write it was a
question she asks him what do you think qualifies
you to work this establishment and he resorts back
well you know i did five tours of duty here but i
don't see how that will help me at it you know and
her response back as well it can be a battlefield
in here sometimes especially during the summer
i'm just like i would have never thought of
that and that's the greatest answer to that line
to that ever um and i love the fact
that this woman who's a manager at
a dairy queen in the coastal mountains of
oregon was literally quoted in la weekly
so that's that's the beauty of having a non-actor
is they can bring that level of realness to
that's their daily life and so if you
just let them be themselves but that's
the hard part as a director is you can't you
can't direct them you literally give them
um the scenario and then just trust them to be
themselves and then hopefully you get what you
need out of it so you're also not getting a lot
of takes uh you do more than two or three takes
they start getting self-conscious and then you've
lost them you had a 300-plus page production bible
yes can you tell us when you started
assembling that and did you leave anything out
see the production bible i'd never compiled
anything like this before other than obviously
editing a feature i guess is a bigger task but
with this film because it was a very modest budget
and uh and i guess because i just wanted to
drive myself insane i decided not only was i
directing and shooting it but i was also
going to be doing the production design
props costumes set dressing all of that and
so i knew if i didn't have every detailed or
written down i would lose track first day into
shooting i would have no idea what shot is next
i would if i just had a shot list i wouldn't
remember like well what was the composition
what was i even think why was i you know why did
i want to just stay in close-ups the whole time
why didn't i want to have so i knew i needed to
have it all laid out so i had all the storyboards
i had all the every scene was broken
down by each shot in each shot what
props were needed what costumes were needed
which actors were in it which were extras
vehicles the location everything broken down
because i knew if i didn't have that you know
i'd only done one feature before but i
knew in that one there were times where
jared and i would be looking at the script in the
shot list trying to remember like wait how did
that scene end okay that scene ended in a close-up
so we can't start this one with a close-up
and we're like no wait no no we ended it with
a wide shot so okay we do start this one with
like trying to figure out the visual language
and i was you know jaren for the longest time
was a crutch for me the guy's just you know
a master of visual storytelling that i didn't
really have to worry about it much well you know
he's doing big movies now so i was like well i
guess i'll just shoot this one myself and uh um
but yeah without having him as a crutch i was
really nervous going into it and then having so
many different responsibilities creatively on it
i had to and i'm so glad i did because if i
didn't have that production bible this thing
would have been a just a flaming train wreck so
any advice to filmmakers on how they should begin
one maybe it won't be 300 plus pages but but but
just a more condensed version i mean definitely
have all those elements because if you're if
you're doing a lower budget film you probably
don't have somebody who's a department head for
all the props and adora ahead for costumes and
all that you probably have if you're lucky of one
person that's overseeing that sometimes it's just
you know everybody's taking turns on it and you've
got actors bringing their own wardrobe or whatever
but if you do that breakdown you think
about things like okay in this scene
these three guys get bitten by a vampire so
their shirts are going to get bloody which
means i am bringing their shirts because i'm not
paying for their laundry bills uh plus probably
won't wash out so knowing that type of stuff and
then just realizing um you know when you're doing
that when you're doing that shot list you start
thinking about little things that you wouldn't
necessarily think about like um there's a scene
in it where he throws a cell phone out the window
it wasn't until i was going through really like
putting together this production bible where i'm
like oh i need to bring a disposable phone i
need to bring a phone that's dead so or that
nobody wants any more otherwise i guess
it'll be my phone we throw out the window
so that sort of thing like you know uh trying
to reach out to friends like hey anybody got
an old cell phone they don't need anymore
that still powers on stuff like that like
i wouldn't have thought of that and so i highly
recommend putting together not just a shot list
but really some level of production bible where
you know every day when you walk on the set
you've already gone through a checklist of
the props that you need the costumes you need
making sure you have the people that you need
and all sorts of stuff and granted a lot of
that's a producer you know producer role
other department heads but we just on this
one it was really i mean michael is an amazing
producer and he handled the logistics well but
a lot of the department heads were me and other
people just kind of putting our heads together
and so we've got you know nika helping as a
production coordinator but she's also acting in
you know quarter of the movie uh you've got
sarah as my aed and script supervisor but
she's also acting in part of the movie um as
well as she's helping jeff black with sound
and she's helping with getting you know helping
michael arrange food deliveries and all sorts of
stuff like we're all pulled in so many different
directions the fact that we could all go back to
this production bible and see oh we got this we've
got this this is taken care of this is checked off
it's a great feeling and there's nothing like
finishing the day and just seeing everything
on the page checked off it's the greatest
feeling in the world like we got it all
we can go to sleep now so i highly recommend
it it's a lot of tedious work to start with
but it's the most gratifying thing while
you're shooting because just knowing you
got everything and be able to check it all off as
you accomplish it it just gives you peace of mind
and are you just getting like a three-ring
binder yeah and then and then putting in
stuff in these like plastic um exact separators
yeah it is it's just it's a three-ring binder
um i've got uh basically each scene has a
divider between it so um when i'm making
it that's the other hard part is like so
i made it just in the order of the script
but then once michael and i had our shooting
schedule down i reorganized it by day so it's
like okay well we're doing this this day so
that was the tricky part with this one because
you know certain scenes just like in any film
you break them up this one's being shot at that
part of the day this was being tried that part of
the day we hadn't we had certain scenes that part
of them were shot in laughlin part was shot in
vegas and part was shot in la um so breaking it
up by day was also essential because be like
okay on day you know once you get to day 20
you know the script doesn't even mean anything to
you anymore it's all abstract at that point it's
like you know your brain is just such a jumbled
mess so you can look at okay on day 20 oh good
okay we're doing the apartment scene so we
don't have to deal with crowds don't deal
with the casino and deal with that but you know
we've got to make sure we have the blood bags
we've got to make sure that we have her running
shoes and we have to have this and that so it just
it was it was essential for that and then um
like i said just breaking it down by day was
essential too and we just have a divider between
each one and then outside of course have the
pdf file and i would just each day print out a
couple copies for everybody to have so that way
you know again checklist uh nika
going through costumes making sure
we had extras costumes and we had the you know
that vania had the right shirt on that day that
matched with the other scenes and stuff like that
so um yeah i highly recommend keep it as organized
as possible as thorough as possible again it's
tedious it's a very tedious process i spent
probably as much time playing the production
bible as i did the first draft of the script
but it saved me so many times and he helped just
kept it all organized i didn't have to think like
i could look you see uh you know right here you've
got your uh shot uh the storyboard with the shot
description underneath it and you can see all
the shots lined up she's like oh that's why i
decided to go in for a close-up here because
it was described and it made sense whereas if
it just been storyboard or shot list it
wouldn't have worked for me now granted
that's if you have you know not everybody
needs storyboards we didn't do it on fray
um partly because oftentimes i would just defer to
jaren on visuals but you know not everybody needs
that but i feel like the more information you have
the better because that's one thing i did find was
scary when i was doing fray is that feeling
of forgetting even what you were doing it's
like wait where are we today we've shot
like four scenes and we're going into five
i don't remember what this is in the script i
remember what i was trying to accomplish with it
um so yeah i just think
it's essential to have that
how do you plan a shoot where you know there will
be rain where rain is an actual part of the scene
um i try not to write too much
around mother nature because
while she can be an amazing gaffer at times
she also can be very finicky um and in fact
fray i'd initially written it i mean we shot
it in march in the coastal mountains of oregon
thinking it was just going to be gloomy gray and
wet the whole time and it was so sunny while we
were shooting we'd go to lunch and the waitress
would be like oh you're so lucky it's never this
nice in the spring i was like oh i wanted gloom i
wanted rain um that being said when it does happen
i you know this is a budget thing when it comes
to mother nature in terms of rain and the elements
i always prefer artificial to the real deal um
shooting in the real rain is just it's hellish
um you know especially if you don't have proper
you know if you don't have a huge budget you have
all the proper tents and the proper housing
for the camera and all that sort of stuff
it's i mean the anxiety of like oh i don't want to
get the camera wet so you've got your ac instead
of pulling focus he's got an umbrella over your
head um you know all that type of stuff i try
to use artificial rain and snow or whatever
when i can now granted usually it's commercial
projects that have that budget it's not my own
uh but even you know shooting vegas the best
in laughlin the best time we had was uh was
august in august in nevada is not pleasant um
poor adushola was crammed to the back of
that prius for three nights of shooting
in the trunk monitoring audio and and sound
while i'm up in the passenger seat shooting it
and we have no air conditioning on it's 100
you know for audio but you know 115 degrees
outside um so yeah i personally try to avoid
the elements as much as possible because i just
like i could never do the revenant that would
i would uh i'd probably give up about a weekend
um i know some filmmakers love that type
of stuff i personally i prefer to i prefer
uh you know even if it's something as simple as
a garden hose for rain i'll use that you know
put your thumb over it have it far enough away
get the rain use some post effects to kind of
gloom it up a little bit and add some depth to
it um that's the joy of knowing how to do some
basic special effects as i know how to i know
how to fake a lot of that type of stuff and do
it where it looks convincing enough that people
don't notice that it's fake what's your favorite
scene in the movie flood from stone uh favorite
scene it's a tough one um i'm kind of it's
like my friend bobby who plays mike the convention
goer his death scene every time i see it i text
him and just tell him how much i love watching
him die um he just i love that scene uh
you know gabby's performance in it is just vicious
and so cold and just great turning points i like
that one but i really think my favorite one is
uh is the conversation with nika and vanya's
uh you know victoria and yuri just brother and
sister just you know shooting the [ __ ] having
a great time with getting a little drunk and just
talking about the good old days and their back and
forth and their dynamic it was a fun scene to
write it's obviously somewhat exposition heavy
they tried to make it fun and then just their
deliveries like they brought it to life so well
that for me it's the first dialogue scene i've
ever written that i'm actually really proud of
and a lot of it is really their their
delivery and the way that they're just
you know so great together on camera
and even though it's a long scene
i enjoy it every time i see it i just love what
they did with it so that's my favorite yeah i
think you learn a lot about the characters and
their motivations from that scene i mean i don't
wanna i don't know if this is a spoiler but is
it that and we may have to take this out where
she says like dad's gonna cut you off if you don't
clean up your act yeah yeah and then you go oh now
i see this guy better okay now i get some of
who he is you know yeah like you can see he's
kind of like the black sheep the rebellious
one the guy that you know never you know
especially for people are into vampire lore you
know for the first like half the movie like these
are weird vampires and then when nika's character
arrives you start to find out why they're so
different like she's really a lot more of this
typical vampire image and type of personality type
and then you start to see why the two that you've
been following are not like the vampires that
you would normally see in a movie and you know
again try not to be too exposition heavy or too
too heavy-handed trying to make it fun the whole
way through but really allowing their backgrounds
like you see why she has such uh animosity
toward him you see why he is so lonely why
he acts the way he does um recently uh a person
that watched it was uh talking about how chatty
he is like he's a chatty vampire and then he as it
goes on he starts to realize like oh this guy is
like lonely like he's a monster and he doesn't
have anyone left in his life like he's a lonely
person who just kind of wants to be loved and so
um you know even though he's a monster and he's
done terrible things to people like he started
just you know so that sort of aspect i um and
that's really the scene where it really comes out
like he and vanya does just such a great job with
being both this just barbarian beast but
also being very vulnerable and very uh
almost like this like childlike innocence
like he's this guy that just never grew up
um never learned how to take no for an answer or
have to have responsibility or anything like that
and uh yeah so i think he just you know he
delivers so well in that one like there's a
there's one moment of it that still every time his
line delivery just brings a little tear to my eye
i'm just like you just like oh that's really
sad and he just he just sells it so well so
how are you releasing blood from stone it's a
good question we're still sorting it out because
everything's kind of been thrown topsy turvy
with the whole covid lockdown stuff you know
the initial plan of doing like a limited little
theatrical release and then going to vod kind of
got torpedoed and going straight to vod there's
nothing wrong with that and i'd be fine with it
but trying to figure out something and so you know
who knows fingers crossed i hope this can happen
talking about doing driving theaters seeing
about that possibility so i would love to
i think i think it's the right type of film for
that frey would have been terrible for drive-ins
that's just not the right atmosphere for it
i think this one could be a fun one for that
so i'm hoping we can make that work but um if it
doesn't and either way it'll you know go straight
it'll also same time go to vod and streaming
services but um it may you know depending on
you know what any rights finds out with the whole
market there they've got one film to try it out
with first before mine so depending on how that
goes we'll see if it's if it's worth doing um
you know people actually show up for no-name
indies at drive-ins then it'd be great
um unfortunately we don't have a
lot of name cache in terms of uh
uh drawing in audiences so it's really
gonna depend on what audiences are up for
and with the vod strategy i mean that's where
you're going to find most your audience anyways
with a a no name indie and sometimes it takes time
i mean it took fray not only did we reach those
heights it took almost four years for it to peak
at you know top 15 ward military films so you know
it's not like the old days where you release it
you have a big boom of attention and then it kind
of drifts off it's like you know it's a long game
with distribution with a no name indy it's like
you know at first people might get a little bit of
attention from reviews from all that type of stuff
but it's still gonna be uh you know it's gonna
take time to build up that grassroots unless you
got you know 100 000 to dump into marketing
it's going to be word of mouth people that
see it recommend it to somebody else that person
recommends it to somebody else and then hopefully
enough people start watching it that the you
know algorithms of all these different websites
start clicking in and start lifting it up in
the rankings and then you know you get enough
reviews on amazon you get enough reviews on imdb
and stuff like that people start taking notice
and uh so it's kind of like we're doing everything
we can to try and like you know build up enough of
a release for it that it'll have the attention to
make at least at least a little bit of a splash
you know um fray fray was a hard one it was uh
when it first came out until the la times review
came out i couldn't pay anyone to care about that
movie um even with our festival wins it was hard
to get anybody to really care um you know we had
some distributors interested but in terms of media
interviews nobody cared um it you know the
la times review really turned that around
but even then it was like that was too
that was the day it was released so it was
too late to create a splash so it became
again about the long game this one hopefully
it'll be a little bit of both hopefully once it
releases be able to get a lot of great reviews
or you know really hope they're it's great
reviews but you know we get a lot of reviews
get a lot of attention for it and then it can
build up that word of mouth because you know
thanks to streaming your film it's not like the
old video store days where you know your film
will be on the shelf for a week and then the
next week would be in the bargain bin um it's
online as long as those platforms last so uh you
know you got time to make back your investment as
long and that was going back to like that quote
from michael madison from indie rights where he
you know be able to do it for a price where you
can make your money back on vod is essential
um you're not going to make back a 2 million
budget or a 5 million budget through vod alone
but you can with you know with smaller budgets so
how does the buzz from blood from stone compare
to fray i mean already even though the film's
not out yet the buzz for blood from stone is
infinitely more than it was for frey um
frey it was wild because you know we got
grand jury prize dance with films got a
couple of the best film awards stuff like that
and even with that it was so hard to get
anybody to care about a no-name depressing drama
um about you know veterans issues it's kind of
like box office poison um so you know we had
distributors interested the reason i liked going
with indie rights was because they were much more
they seemed very honest and straightforward about
what to expect from the movie i didn't trust any
distributor that said it was going to do great
um but uh and they did they delivered on it but
it was so hard to get anybody to care i mean even
just getting a blogger to interview us was a chore
um whereas this one i had a teaser trailer cut
about a year ago like right after we wrapped
shooting i had a teaser trailer cut and lyndon
michael had it for one of the film markets just
wanted to show people about this film that they
have in the works and uh you know it'll be coming
out in a year and the thing literally got pirated
from a private server and leaked out to youtube
it's like i could like literally nobody watched
my trailer for frey when i released it little
and pirated it um so it was weird to think
that and had similar issues like the new
trailer that just released like as soon as we
put it out it was popping up every on a bunch
of other sites and so it's just interesting to do
a movie that people are actually excited to see
um now again there's no big names but it you
know apparently from i mean it's always hard
when you're critics i look at it and i just see
a lot of stuff i wish i could have done better or
that sort of thing but the reception i'm
getting from it from people have seen it is that
you know it looks like a really exciting very high
production value film uh just indifferent you know
people love the fact that it looks different so
it's really crazy to see that that being said
there's still you know there's gonna be a lot
of work put into amplifying that buzz and that's
that's the i would say my least favorite
part about the whole filmmaking process
is the marketing promotion side of it
it's like you know takes this thing that
for so long has been this pure art form
and now i'm turning into a commodity
and trying to sell it like okay what is gonna sell
this and all of it just feels cheap and wrong um
so that's the part i'm trying to get my brain
wrapped around we can we don't have much of a
budget so it's you know so much that's going to
be in the hands of myself and the cast and crew
to really self-promote it as much as possible
um and so i'm grateful for the fact that there's
already been some interest and people just seem to
really like what they see with it uh and i guess
knowing you know if anyone that at least looks
into me knowing that you know coming from the
world of doing something like fray knowing that
if i'm doing a vampire movie it's not going to be
you know typical i think that's helping too
what are your expectations from blood from stone
the expectations that keep me awake at night
are the ones that i'm optimistically hoping for
maybe both um yeah i uh i don't know i tend to
be a very hopeful pessimist uh i really hope that
that this film can speak on a deeper level to
people like i made it intentionally it's very
i hope it's a really entertaining
feeling people enjoy and they walk out of
being like that was a fun ride um you know
some of those films i mentioned earlier
that i grew up loving all of them were a fun ride
it didn't matter how serious or dark they got
they're also kind of a thrill to watch
like i wanted to do that but i also
you know we did a test screening of it and during
the you know we had them everybody fill out a form
answering some questions and afterwards just
you know ask them a few questions and a few
of them said like i actually don't know what to
say about the movie yet there's a lot to process
and i like that i don't know you know
what they're going to come you know
what people are going to come back with they might
process it and go wow that was a you know lord a
load of horse crap um or maybe they'll process
it and it'll speak to him on a lot of levels uh
but i just hope that you know it's one that
does at least make people think um make
you know reflect on their own past their own
actions how you know how our actions can infect
others lives how you know how somebody you know
so much of the politics and social stuff going on
thinking about the impact of the past not just
my own personal past actions but historical
past actions of an era that's putting me in the
position that i'm in now that allows me to have
advantages that others don't have and how that
might breed resentment how that might and try to
understand why people might not you know
might have some animosity might have some some
feelings that aren't overly positive even though
i personally don't feel i've done anything wrong
um those sorts of ideas or for somebody that's
dealt with an abusive relationship for them
to find that strength to to escape from
it and to know that going out on your own
no matter who you are or where you're coming
from and going out on your own means having
that freedom to make mistakes so that's what i'm
really hoping for is i like films that make you
think i like films that afterwards you have a long
discussion about i remember you know watching uh
the movie enter the void couldn't stand that film
but was mind blown by at the same time i was like
i mean friends i wouldn't see with we had a
four hour conversation after the movie just
about the movie um and i still personally not a
fan of the film hated all the characters in it
but it was an amazing film that just like
i have so much more respect for something
like that than something you walk out of
and you start thinking about like wait i
don't even remember what i just watched so
that's what i'm hoping to get out of it um
and then on an aspirational side i would love
for it to do well because honestly i want to
do a sequel for it i really do i want i want
to explore the matriarchy of this vampire clan
i want i want to meet their mom i want to see uh
victoria and her wife claudia i want to see where
uh daria's life goes and i want i want
to be able to do that story so that's
the aspirational hope for it is that uh it
does well so i can keep exploring that world
is that your next project or that's just
theoretically in the future it'd be more
expensive than this one so this movie better
do really well otherwise that's not happening
cause that one requires castles and i also
want to have flashbacks to when uh when uh uray
first met daria and where her animosity for
him started why she has a you know a grudge
against him uh i want to show her life you know
kind of where it was dealing with that cyclical
nature of existence and you know uh civilizations
and all that i would love the sequel to actually
explore that show literally have those flashbacks
of the past and how those are so tied to the
the now and the present and be able to show that
full circle as opposed to just talk about it so
yeah i would love to go that direction with it
if i can um if not i have another micro budget
script that i'm working on that deals with a lot
of other similar themes but is also a passion
project that i've had for a while fermenting in
the back of my head if you were gonna teach your
own impromptu film class what five movies would
you require the students to watch oh wow okay um
five movies i would have them watch the first one
i already mentioned it uh samsara um just the most
pure perfect form of filmmaking uh that film i
saw it four times in theater made me cry every
time at the end it is one of those powerful films
i've ever seen and there's not a word of dialogue
or narration it's literally images music and
profound storytelling so that one just as an
experiment in like this is the purest form of
cinema there is uh at least in my perspective um
the other one steve mcqueen's hunger remember
walking out of hunger being both mind blown and
depressed because i realize i'll never make a film
nearly that good but mcqueen's ability to make the
most visceral exhausting brutal movie that is
composed of long takes and almost no speaking
uh is just breathtaking again just pure
perfect cinema so definitely those two
then it would be uh dr strangelove uh for that
one is just how like the perfect political
satire the perfect film for you know you
take a director like kubrick is so known for
heavy heavy films with very like nuanced
performances and just to go over the top and
to be able to dissect them i could talk
about that one for a long time but just how
that film has all the trademark kubrick
things but done in such a different way
and to really understand comedy if you don't
know comedy your films are going to be boring
i understand how comedy works i
think is so essential to filmmaking
uh you know i if i had one regret
about freights i didn't have enough
levity in it uh so definitely that one um god what
would it be uh so that's three yeah i think um
oh uh i would have to go like way back
to um did you ever see uh force of nature
uh i forget even the director's name but i only
found out about it because uh scorsese said an
interview is one of his favorite films like
well i gotta check it out it's a film noir um
it's such a it's a you know because it's older
it's a little bit simpler it's not relying on
like extreme production value or whatever
pacing dialogue performance all the plot
points is one of the most efficient enjoyable
films i've ever seen so that one just for like
efficient smart storytelling it's so good
and then oh god um probably honestly like
a j.j abrams movie just because the
guy like if you want to make money
learn from the master this guy does
pop culture movies better than anybody
you know him or spielberg one of those two where
it's like you know take one of their big hits
and like never forget to entertain your audience
either i think is like a key part of filmmaking
is you know you can learn all the artistry of
the craft have all the heady stuff in there
but don't forget people paid money or gave you
time of their life and let them enjoy it too so
that'd be my my course that'd be your course okay
and uh what would be the hardest curriculum i
mean sorry what would you say what would be the
hardest uh part of the curriculum what would be
the one like sort of like tough love uh part of
the class that uh maybe the students would back
at but you feel like they would need to know um
i don't know i think like my own regret actually
i used to do i used to do talks at different
film schools and i always would tell people
the one thing that and you'll hate to hear this
because i didn't listen to it when i was younger
and the only way i ever learned this was tripping
and falling flat on my face a hundred times
running into walls trying to look for an exit on
a doorway to the next step learn how to start up
a business if every film you do is a business
startup and if you don't know how to properly
start up a business you are going to lose your ass
for my language you're going to you're going to
you know it's unless you unless you're fortunate
enough to have you know a proper investors and
a producer an executive producer and all those
people that are managing that for you if you're
doing like bootstraps like making your own film
your way with whatever proceeds you could wrangle
up you're making you're starting up your own
business approach it as one no matter how low your
budget is have a strat have a startup strategy
have a marketing strategy have all that from
the moment that you're like oh
this is the script i'm gonna make
from that moment on start treating it like a
business as well because if you don't you're
gonna make a lot of lot of dumb mistakes that
i've made a hundred times and learned the hard way
so i would honestly if i was truly teaching
a filmmaking course i would have a whole
section on business startups and and you know
what do they say ninety percent of startups fail
so let filmmakers know that you know most films
fail go into that knowing it uh if you're not
willing to accept failure then you'll never
make something original because you're going
to be constantly trying to make something that's
going to please people which means it's going to
be based on what already exists and if you're
not willing to go out on a limb then you're not
going to succeed so you got to be willing to
accept there's a good chance i'm going to fail
you know i was saying it earlier fray i expected
nobody was going to watch it um and i got lucky
people did um with this one i hope people want to
watch it but there's a part of me that's really
braced forward to just tank i have no idea and i
would never want to go into a film expecting it
to be a success because then you're just setting
yourself up for disappointment so that would be
that'd be my thing is accept failure learn from it
and know that failure is what leads to originality
and then learn business